You
Hello my pretty
Hello
Hi, welcome I am the witch you have heard of
Welcome to witch heavies summer weed
Are
You scared you know what might take the edge off some wine perhaps it's not blood I swear
Yeah
Why hi everyone hello
Hello, hello, hello my display I must have out I
I
Am so excited for the stream today. I did lots of shopping. I am very excited to show you the witchy side of myself
Did some yeah, I did some shopping. I got some I got my nails done
Do you like it?
I can't
I
Promise you they'll look better like when I take a picture on my phone rather on this really crappy webcam
I promise you I promise you I promise you she did such a good job. The camera is generally just not doing it justice
Um I
Also, it's funny because I have a purple crystal ball. Wait, will it what reflect me?
You can kind of see me you can't see my face though
So I won't I won't have the crystal ball out
But when I color correct, that's a good idea let me color color correct my hand
Red and see what happens
Or is it what as I do that today
What the heck this is looks weird
About this now I'm just really pale
What if I
Is that it
I'm changing the filter on the wrong thing that is even showing let's go
This actually looks kind of cool, I'm not gonna lie
Satinous
Me
I
Look how great is maybe I'll turn down the saturation like a little because it actually
Kind of breathe some color into me
Now whatever it's very grainy though. I
Don't know why it's so grainy
But that looks a little bit better. I
Need a new webcam
Hello, hello, welcome in welcome in my name is
My name is she be cotton bum and today I will be
Reading your tarot
Oh, how funny how fitting that the fool is on the bottom deck energy of the fool is the first
Card in the major arcana. I can't I
Forget where my camera placement is it's like far away for me. I should probably scooch forward. Um, so that's very funny
It's new beginnings. That's very very fitting. Um,
Some of you may be aware
That I am a practitioner of the dark arts
Yes, I believe in the the mumbo jumbo
I am one of the astrology bitches if you are just kidding. I'm not really into astrology
Um, but I am a spiritual practitioner. Um, it is something that I've talked about before. I'm not Wiccan
I'm not Wiccan. I will say I'm not I just say I'm just like pagan or whatever. Um
Wiccan Wiccan takes a lot of stuff from paganism. So it but it like Wiccan is his own thing. Um, but
Yeah
I kind of wanted to show you this part of myself when the summer wean thing is really I've been a practitioner for uh five years
Um, some of you guys know I used to be a good little christian girl. That is not the case anymore
I need to like move my
Set up because I'm being pulled by my gox lr when I try to turn
Um, let me turn on
Desktop audio so you guys
Can hear do you hear double you probably hear double audio actually? Oh, why does it do that?
Um, oh wait, I know what to do. Ho ho ho. Duh
Perfect now you guys can't hear double audio
That's too loud
My microphone is kind of behind me because uh, my desk is L shaped and so it's over like there
Um, so if I sound like I'm far away from the microphone, I apologize
So how does one get a terror reading done? I see I'll do one for you for free
Um, but I will be charging money
Like the filthy fake psychic I am
Um, no, I'll probably I'm kind of debating whether or not to do three or five dollars
Just because I know there's gonna be probably a couple people watching and I was kind of overwhelmed last time
um
But uh, I'm lighter than it
I'm lighter than a a laden swallow. How about that? Um
But
Yeah, and um, I won't lie to you. It's it's it's actually
Emotionally taxing and physically taxing to read for so many people. You're working with a lot of energies. You know, um
But let me see. I'm trying to
Do I want to turn this this way a little bit? Yeah, that's better because like
Cool. All right. Um
I didn't go out and buy this stuff
Again, I've been a pro practitioner
for hi
Hey, I've been a practitioner for five years. My altar sits above my desk. I just put all my stuff out here
I have this is my tapestry. My friend got me. I have some selenite. I have some clear quartz
I have some labradorite
spirit quartz amethyst
obsidian
rose quartz some candles. I have a
A candle dedicated to the green man who is in
uh
Gaelic mythology folklore and belief system. I have my little my little baby cauldron
Um
And I also have some like snuffing stuff. I have my singing bowl. Um
And I have some like you can't see it, but I well you can actually can't see it. I have some um
I'm just spices. Well, they are spices essentially. I have some herbs over here
um
so
I I ask of you
To approach this with an open mind
I ask of you
You do not have to believe in what I'm you can just see this as a little fun party trick that I'm doing
That is totally okay
If you have a belief system where this is really scary for you
You don't have to see it as real. Don't you worry. Okay. Yes secret blend seven herbs and spices. Um
You will not go to hell
But if this makes you uncomfortable, I'm so sorry
But you can just see it as a little fun a little pre-holloween stuff
Um, I always say if you get your cards read
You can take it with a grain of salt. Um
You can just see it. For example, I pulled up the full which is at the bottom of the deck. This is
This is a deck I use for reading on stream because it has words so people can understand
Uh, when I hold up the card what it's saying, I don't know if it'll focus and my hands are shaky. Um, so the full for example
represents new beginnings innocence originality fearlessness free spirit fresh hope taking chances new paths
Spontaneity and leap of faith
So you can look at this card and not be like, oh the spirits are telling me that I should be doing
No, you can just say, oh, maybe I should work on that project that new project that I've been putting off and putting off
It's time for a new beginning. You can use this as a sort of self-reflective
therapy
There's no such thing as a coincidence. If you're watching this you are
spiritually connected and aligned with my energy. Um
But if you're a vod watcher and you're seeing this in the future, you know what you're seeing
You are seeing this for a reason some of the messages and this might apply to you. Um in my past life
I did these a lot. My whole thing was being a an occult priestess in my pl
And I did a lot of terror readings and I did I did a couple spell jars and I did a lot of origins of pagan stuff because
And it's also part of my culture. I'm Haitian
uh Haitian uh voodoo is where um
Is voodoo is from Haiti? I can't talk uh voodoo is from Haiti. It originated as Haiti
It originated in Haiti in which was taken from um slaves from Africa and also mixed with the indigenous peoples
in their belief systems. Um
I personally don't practice voodoo because that's a little hard core for me
But I do acknowledge it and it is it is something I've done a lot of research on it. Um
But yes, voodoo is popular in New Orleans. That is very very true
voodoo is very popular in New Orleans because a lot of again slaves came from Haiti
Went to Louisiana and brought their voodoo. Um, but it did originate in Haiti, which I am um
Uh, very proud. It's there's a lot of culture a lot of spiritual
Uh culture that was taken from Africa that ended up in Haiti. I know you're wondering like wow, you're so pale
How are you from Haiti? I'm sorry. It's the camera. I am black. I swear to god
My mom is like I'm biracial guys. My dad was born in Haiti and immigrated. I swear. I'm not just I'm not some crazy
Uh girl just pretending. I'm something. I'm not I'm not
I didn't want to say anything. I was kind of confused that you're it's fine. You're good. Um
Um, I would love to do a a collab with emmy. Um, just so I can teach you some of the safety stuff of spiritual work. Um
Oh my god, my neighbors just scared the crap out of me because I heard them walk away. Um
So, uh
I have some amplifiers here, but I also have some protective stone. So obsidian is used for protection and grounding. Um,
Um
Clear quartz is used for amplifying spirit quartz. Uh, the spirit quartz is I got it from a uh rock dealer
And this is to kind of better help connect with the spiritual realm
Um, we think we did we get raided? Hi. Hi. Hi everybody. Hello. Hi. Hi. Can I
Hey there
Um, maybe the deadly alliance immortal combat queefling raid. Hi. Welcome in. Hi. I'm stevie. Hello. Hello. Hello
Rock dealer or rock dealer. Uh rock dealer rock on bro. Um
But yeah, so I also have some stuff to make spell jars
So I'll show you some of the spell jars that I've made before
Um member reeflings joining. Hi member reeflings. I hope you had a good member stream
We
I look so far away from the camera. We
Is there a spell to get sheebie to sit on my face? Uh
Let me think hold on
Alakazam Alakazoo shebees now sitting on you. That's the spell. Um
Thank you for the super bomb. Thank you for the super. Hold on. I need to turn my camera. So it's actually looking at me
Um, so I'll show you some of my spell jars I've made in the past
um
I don't think miracles is that effective?
So, uh, I've made a couple I've made it like I think two on stream before in my pl
Uh, let me pull these down. So I made a
um
spiritual jar and this was uh for the purpose of
manifestation and abundance
And I actually made this uh a week before I applied for the velar
Auditions
Um
And then this one I use as a sort of overreaching kind of protection
um spell
Shiny rock suppliers are interesting a lot and just like kind of guarding and safekeeping
um kind of just
Just your
Just self preservation and just good health and stuff. Um, and also a little bit of manifestation to the star and I use on top
um
pukeling raid and I also have one
uh
A love one I did for self love a little bit ago
I don't even know how old this is. I I had more spell jars. I don't know where they are. Um, so
I and then my friend bought me one
She got it from a store
I have I'm like, why would you spend money on that? I could have made that myself, but you know
Thank you for the thought. I hate that you spent 30 dollars on a jar of stuff that I could have done
Um showing off my spell jars. Yes. Hi. Hello. He told me. Tell my nose. What's up. Tell my nose. What's up?
She's a she's a fellow card reader. Um
What does the store bought one do the store bought one is for abundance
Is another one I will literally hold on. I
It literally says abundance on it. I can't really show you because it has the brand name
And where it was crafted not that like not that I live there, but I don't want people to like triangulate my location
Um
Do you want to improve your luck? I could definitely make one to improve luck. Um
But yeah, so like I also have some floor to water floor to water is using a lot of um
Cleansing rituals. It looks like it's actually it's cologne. It's like it smells so good
It smells so good. It's like cloves cinnamon. Um, let me see
Just as fragrances doesn't say what but it smells absolutely delicious and it's also used for protection. Um
You sorry
I feel like people are gonna make a binding of isaac and uh call the lamb references
Yeah, it's literally called florida water. I don't know why
It you can't drink this. It's literally alcohol
There's alcohol in this I've had this for a while because I just I'll just take some and dab it on me
Uh, why specifically florida?
That's a great question. I suggest you google it
Have you ever dealt with people who would shame you for being interested in voodoo? Um
Um
Not really because a lot of my friends are practice practitioners. We're just like a little witchy like
Trio me olive and salam. That's literally what we call our salam is because she's so witchy. Um
And no, like my friends are cool with it and even if people don't believe in it
I would literally bring my tarot to work and I'd have like
Super freaking christian people ask me to read their cards and then come back later and be like wow, you were right
Like wow, thank you for telling me this wow. Thank you for guiding me this way. Thank you for blah blah blah blah blah
I remember like crying profusely reading someone's cards and I'm like who hurt you. Whoa
What did they do to you?
I have I will take a picture of my setup afterwards, but it is hilariously precarious and dangerous
I'll tell you that much. Um
But yeah
That's blasphemy the pig in which yeah, they're the pig in which committee. They're very sweet very kind very accepting
Um, I know this might put a lot of people off from me, but this isn't in my content
I don't really do this in my content
I've done it once I did like randomly did terror reading after a tom and gachi stream because I was like
Let's do something else. Oh my tarot cards are right there
But this is not my predominant content. You will probably see me do this again in uh around halloween, but otherwise
I'm not going to be doing this often. So it makes you uncomfortable. I totally understand where you're coming from
I totally respect your feelings. Um, but yeah, just think of yeah, think of me as one of the hex girls
Will you draw a card for harem? Yeah, I can do for so what I'm going to do. I'm going to do some cleansing
Um, I'm going to light some candles. So I have the green man candle. That's what I use to dedicate as presents for the spirits
I have a black candle for protection
um
Again, I have my uh, I don't know if you can tell but I have a five pointed star right here
And there's also a five pointed star on my rocks
My stones my gems. Um, but yeah, even though I'm not specifically into this kind of stuff
Find it relaxing a smart people to terror reading for people. Yeah, don't forget to shield. Yes
I'm gonna I'm probably mentally going to shield and stuff. Um
Because it's gonna be very overwhelming with this many people watching me. I don't know. I like so one of my favorite
um
YouTubers who is uh like a terror reader is shonetta divine tarot
She's so sweet and kind, but she streams to like a thousand people or more and I'm like, I don't know how I could do that
That's a lot
Um, but yeah, my crown shot. Yeah, I have some amethyst to protect that
um, I have I have
I have been mentally preparing for this moment to have a wide audience
You know, because it will be very exhausting for me. Um
Get my rocks off
Rowing which city watching a girl look off bunny makes spelled jars life is good. Um
But yeah
Nails look great. Yeah, they look really good. You can't they look better. Uh, like I'll take an actual picture
Do you like my do you guys like my my golf like I went to hot topic and I kind of miss it now
I think I might start shopping a hot topic again. I'm like, dude. What the heck? Why is this kind of a banger?
I almost bought a shirt. I I'm I saw a good charlotte shirt and I was like, should I?
For shibony and I was like, no, no, no, no, no. I got it. This is already too much money
I spent 30 dollars for rings. Look at guys. I'm married to you guys and um
This this like hand stuff like this this is like something I already had this outfit
Hot topic and spencers. I know I should have gone to spencers. There's a spencers across the way
Um chains are fire. Yeah, be quitting the prep activity. Um
She's 30 no in total
So like I got like two sets of rings and I got then this thingy
It's like its own separate bracelet and then I got the gloves and then the two sets of rings
So like 10 rings this and these gloves were 30 bucks, which should have been like 10 dollars
But it's whatever you love the sleeves. Oh, I'll show you get hold. Can I
Can I is this allowed?
can I
Hold on
I'm trying to like lead and you can kind I have like I have a whole get up
Going I have like it's all sparkly
Like I don't really know what to tell you. I can't I can't really show it. It's like not really working. Um
Respect
Gough power glove. Oh my god
Oh
Now you're playing with power. I love that song by my party
Uh, but yeah
Yeah, I'm gonna tuck my phone back in my shirt. Um, but yeah, we're got she be today
Don't ignore my head popping off my body. Um
Um
The fit is immaculate boss. Just like last month of membership has been immaculate. Love you boss. Oh, thank you
I think it's really cute. Some of you guys call me boss because like the intern thing like I like it
Fuwa, I will gladly take you with me. Uh, you would
You're so cutesy
Fuwa's room is amazing. She posted her room recently on her twitter and I was like
Bro, that's like heaven. It's funny because like I'm very like like I can be
Gough, but then I'm like, I'm also like my whole desk is pink
Like you can see my foam is pink like everything is pink on my desk. So like I gotta I like golf
But I also like pastel golf. It's it's funny
Um
But yeah, cute golf is a thing. Um
So what we're gonna start with
Is I'm going to start with the spell jar
Uh, I am going to make a collective spell jar for all of us
And I will let you guys decide amongst yourselves what you want the spell jar to be whether it be luck
abundance safety love
self love a success
protection vice versa
A jar jar. Yes jar jar
Me so horny. Sorry
Um
Fertility
Um and another like let me again more disclaimers
You can take what I say with a grain of salt. You don't have to believe in anything
Please do not use my card readings to predict a death
Uh the uh a pregnancy like you don't do that
Make it a warrior jar. No, that's horrible. You've seen what the what the horn scent have done
Meese are ready for these so white
Um, this is not financial advice. Please do not eat bet on what I'm telling you
Please
Um, please
How can a reason predict if the milk in the fridge is going bad? Uh
Yeah, uh, I also have moon water that I've had for a very long time. It probably has mold in it
Wow, actually it doesn't
Can you believe that?
I've had this for two years. This water has been sitting in this jar for two years. I left it outside
Under another uh, I think it was another blue moon
Um
It has just it has just uh a clear quartz in it and that's it and it's perfectly clear
I don't understand
Should I open it? No, you know, I'm gonna leave. I don't really need um
Need that right now
They happen every month not a blue moon. It's like it's it was a super blue
I can't remember what the fuck kind of moon. It was okay. It was a moon
All right, it was similar to the one we had a couple days ago
I'm not gonna drink the moon the the moldy moon water jar
The super blue whatever I said a couple days ago. All right, I have to like reach my arm out out here
Oh, you want to look at this? Oh, you like that?
Oh
Bro, I'm gonna throw you across the room. I'm gonna slam you against my bed. I'll bench your ass. How about that?
Hold on let me just
I think I plucked too hard that hurt. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Wait, wait
Don't fall don't fall don't fall
Oh
Swole just I'm not swole
With my e-mail at the arm
I'm jacked I drank the moon water before stream. No, I'm drinking normal water
I'm drinking normal water
Normal water
Okay, so we're going to do the
Um spell jar I will cleanse everything first. I'm going to protect myself
um
Because I don't want to invite any nasty spirits or entities or ancestors that don't particularly like me or you
Into this reading into my area into my living space
Uh
Everybody alakazam alakazoo shebe's now sitting on you you guys can't see
What I'm doing, um, so you need like you need to wear protection kid
Wrap it up. All right
always wrap it
always
Uh, you can have a haunting stream. No, they don't want to I'll tell you what I had one
Thing that haunted me and I was like, you don't belong here
And I was like, you know what but I'm out and then I just never dealt with that whatever it was again
They just they don't you know spirits don't really
They don't really care about me
They don't really care about anybody depends unless you piss them off. Yeah, we're a spiritual condom. Um
So let me grab some spedge
Some such I'm taking off my headphones. So if you don't know I will not hear it, but I do have text to speak on
Okay, yeah, we don't want any spirits like Chucky. That's a good point. Uh
So I'll actually show you what I'm pulling stuff out of um
So I got this I've uh had this for a couple years now. I'm just gonna place it on top of everything
So I I literally have it's dusty ignore that
Ignore how dusty it is. I have this giant they actually have two more
Uh similar to this but this is a contemporary. Um
What's it called contemporary
Uh
Like early 20th century
Um, I think jewelry box, but I've repurposed it into
Keeping a lot of my spell stuff
So I have some stones like it was a jar. I have my some sage in here
Um, I have some more like I have stuff that I've labeled
Uh hibiscus rose petals rose petals hibiscus. I have some mugwort
Uh, if you remember me my pl
I told you guys that you can use this to abort a child
You can
You can drink this or make it into a tea and trip like you're on mushrooms or abort a child
Uh
Yeah mugwort is crazy
I've never tried it though. I don't think I ever will especially because I just use this for
Uh spell purposes. It'd be weird if I drink it. Um
I also have a jar of honey
For like like uh sweet stuff if I were to make like a sweet spell. Um, so yeah, I'm no joke
I don't uh, this is this is legit for me. I don't
I don't fuck around like some you know people do
On tick talk on witch talk
And I kind of just like I'm making this. Ooh. Do you want to do a hex on somebody?
No, that's stupid. That's dumb. Um, I keep it to myself
I keep my own practice to myself, but I think it's fun to share on stream every once in a while
You got an abortion. You're lying. You're lying to me
Yeah, no hexing the moon. That's just dumb. Um, but yeah
You got some elderberries
Your mother was a hamster and your father smells of elderberries when I went to a run fair somebody screamed that and I
Died ever since I was so funny. Have some salt here
Uh, st. John's wort. I have chased berries, you know
I'll make you guys chase a lock you guys in a chastity bell. I'll put a hex on you that you can never nut
Um, just kidding. That's not what that's for. I have marshmallow
Oh snap. I have marshmallow root
I have a lot of stuff. I used to have stones up here, but I moved them to a different thing. So now it's only, um
Now it's only
Other stuff here. I'll show you my my gem collection
Oh
What's that?
Pardon you
So I organized these by color
I bumped it. Oh no
Are you guys alive?
You guys are
You're fine. Don't worry about it. So what I have you're on a chair
on a box
and I've
Jerry may like I've like MacGyvered this to my ring light
So
Yeah
So I got some black candles there. Don't worry about that. Um, my friend got me this
I was very happy when she gave this to me. Salem got me this. Um, she found it at like a yard sale. Yes
I know it has a mirror. You can't see me
Okay, I just can't see me. I'm doing fortnite dances
Um, so I have some I have some stones
I have some I have some jammies, um, but they're not organized
Sorry, I'm sorry. I saw the floss
She's heading to witty
I got that rug I wanted for since I destroyed the other one during a member stream, um
Any moonstone? Yeah, I have moonstone. I got rainbow moonstone. I got
normal moonstone
I got I got moonstone. Okay, but kind of moonstone you want want to want to buy some
I can't really open a jacket, but we want to buy some gems
um
Let me put this over here actually
Oh
What spells or rituals have you done to ward anything off anything crazy or just normal protection? Um, so
What I do when I clean is like open a door and a lot of people just do this
It's actually a cultural thing people do and they don't realize it
Uh, you know like sweeping stuff out a door or like throwing things out a window or whatever
That's actually a form of getting rid of negative energy
I'm running out of breath because I'm running around
um
So I'll do that and then I'll walk around in sage and then I will take like moon water or like florida water
and I will um
Draw a pentagram on every mirror because mirrors are portals
Don't forget that mirrors are portals
um
Not a pet. Oh, it's like it's not a pentagram. It's like you draw it in the opposite direction. It's like banishment
Um, but yeah, I've done that before
That's when I was having nightmares because what you shouldn't do you should never have a mirror facing your bed
When you sleep, but I'll I I've always had that
So and I always wondered oh, why do I get night terrors? Oh, why do I get nightmares so often? Oh, why do I have such crazy dreams?
um, so I started doing that when I learned about like
being a practitioner
And then then it stopped
Then I wasn't getting night terrors anymore
Um, but yeah, so yeah, and I sage and then get all the energy and and then negative energy out nightmares nightmares nightmares
um
Don't say something five times around the mirror
Uh, oh my god my camera like my camera wire here. I'll I literally will point
So like I seriously have like the why the guys like my toes toes legs free toes
I got my toes done
You can't see but they're purple
Stay I should like tape this to the box
So it's more stable. It's like rocking forward because of the weight. What if I
Sure, okay that works
Yeah for free
Don't say I want to watch that movie though. I can't wait to see the new one. It looks so good. Um
All right, what time is it? It's already been 40 minutes and I have any I've just been explaining and talking
But I hope you guys get the general idea
Uh, no toe beans
And that's why I put I put those little like toe bean things on my throat
um
Far blue thing looks like a bomb. What this?
This what?
Huh, where's the light?
Alakazam
Back to life back to reality black
My eyes oh the the candle so this is a candle holder. This is also a candle holder
This is actually really freaking bright. Can I turn this down?
You know what I like the ambiance and we're gonna light some candles anyway. Um solar flare
It's the florida juice
It's the it's the florida juice
So we sip the moon can get high from an abortion and jars help predict the lottery. Did I get that right?
You would be correct. I'm so happy you've kind of done everything
Um, anyways, I'm gonna light this
No, this is youtube it's sage. This is educational. This is an educational stream
Do you think I would have this much that is ridiculous? I don't even smoke
But she be why do you have that lighter to light stuff what they're not just for cigarettes and other stuff guys
This is strong actually I should have just known a little bit
It's not going back. I'm gonna cleanse the rest of those world actually
Connecting with the spiritual plane connecting with the intentions of the highs and pray is good
Spirits connect me with folks that are be listening to the stream today
Let them gain something from the stream let their minds be opened
And
She's smoking saw on stream. No, bro
Oh
The beautiful day outside for real for real
Oh big stretch, how you doing feel these sleeping?
There's no room for her on my desk
I
I'll be good or what what am I missing am I am I interested in story driven games? I love story driven games
I can't believe I'm out of it
Fair point was the truth. No. Oh
No, the plat there's so many people showing like stuff like this online
On youtube like I there's a lot of tear a lot of tarot readers on youtube and people who will teach you stuff
Um, so it's not youtube's not gonna take me down for this. This is definitely like
Um, like religious expression. I don't really see this as a religion to be honest. I guess
Um
Want to play final fantasy? I've never played final fantasy in my life. Okay. I'm gonna light this candle
Do you like this? It looks like a taser
Hello, don't worry. It looks like it's burning the thing, but it's not I promise you
It is very bright on this camera and then I'm gonna light this
This
And I'm just gonna take a moment
I'm I'm just gonna you're gonna experience a moment of silence to know your which I am baby girl
I don't really like being called a witch, but it is what it is
I'm seeing it. I just need to kind of like center myself and shield myself like Toma mentioned. So I'm gonna do that right now
People watching like oh, she crazy crazy. You're fine. It's cool. Don't worry about it
Hey, man, you're eating a cracker that represents the the body of a dude that died
So, you know, you tell me
um
How should we call you instead? You don't have to call me anything. Just call me she be
What that's a that's a food
All right, so that's good. We're gonna make this did you guys decide what you want in the spell jar
Very very true opinion and wicked rituals aren't any stranger. That's very accurate
Where are my mods mods stop stop people
Oh
Um
Okay, hold on let me let me let me
Let me
Ask question what kind of spell jar
I put lobe instead of love
And when I say love I mean like overarching love for everybody. I'm not going to do a love spell on you guys
I I that's not safe
It's not safe
I don't
I know if I did it
Something bad would happen. I don't want to do that and
I
Already love you enough and you already love me enough that if you think
That a spell jar will make it better then you don't know me at all
All right, you don't know me at all if you think you need a spell jar for me to fucking love you
You're fucking stupid
How about that?
I
No, I'd win do you see my muscles I'd win
Don't put love in the poll while I'm doing love as in like how I'll specify
self love
Uh growth let's do that because you guys are silly. Um
Luck
Yeah, you don't you don't have to believe in any of this you don't have to believe in a damn thing
You're totally
Untitled to that. You don't have to you can just have fun and watch me do funny stuff on youtube
love derogatory
I found someone who sells fast divorce spell and that's terrible
She be witched
I know that I make another channel called she be witched
And it's just me doing all this stuff constant
Wait a second
And I do like collective terror
Wait a minute
Which also
Um
New projects for next year
It's funny when I was when in my pl
I was actually going to do something like this and do a lot of more predominant like
Spiritual content because that's my that was my whole thing
And then I was gonna do set up like a like a thing where if you want you can like send me a dollar
I'll do like a one dollar card reading for you or something. I was gonna do that
Uh
Abundance wealth
Okay, what else? So I have self love
Self love aka growth
Abundance wealth luck
What else happiness
Oh, she she didn't spicy over here. What's up with that?
What's up with that?
This you guys can't tell but this flame just got freaking huge
That means someone's trying to do shit. Someone's talking shit right now. I know it's you stop it. It's not nice
I'm just having fun bro. Stop talking shit. Um success kind of goes with abundance
um
Caught
Um
I'm gonna say I'll say happiness happiness we all want to be happy
The ball panels. No, it looks like it's close, but I promise you it's not it's not
Yeah, I'm sticking my hand in between it there. It's not close
I'm not doing it. Why would I do that?
Everybody just wants money money money money must be funny
Hey
Wait, how's the song go money money money in a rich man's world
Cute setup make it rain. I just take my cards
I'm gonna put some of this on me
Because I can already feel some people wishing me some ill will
I'm gonna dab some
I'm
Florida water protective I'm doing on my crown chakra my heart chakra my throat chakra just so I can speak better
I actually should get some blue kyanite out for
Communication that's actually a really fucking good idea. Let me get through that
Oh blue kyanite
Can't tell if I got a pee
You know, it's funny cuz like, um
Come on can't scooch forward. Um, I'll end the poll at
Luck can bring money as well true. Um, I usually
So like personally I
It's weird because like I'm not super on the thing that
Like rocks
Do stuff
But I'm on the belief that they're helpful reminders
Of repers of what they represent
So like I have a blue kyanite necklace that I would wear when I would go to work
So I would be a better speaker
And if I felt like I was stressing out because it wasn't speaking well enough, I would just kind of ground myself
um with a
A kyanite necklace and just be like no like just take a take a moment
So again, you don't have to be like, oh this rock is vibrating at this frequency
It's gonna heal me and my cancer. No, that's not no
No
One I threw that window did one exactly Fuwa
Their minerals will rain
Can we wish for anti-will? Why would you wish for anti-will?
Yeah, talismans don't need to have actual powers to mean something to you
You can just use them as a sort of reminder a touchstone a hundred percent
So I'm putting this right here. So I remember to talk right here. I'll put it in between here. This will be communication
protection spirits
We love to see it
Well for the pay pigs what?
Well for uh
The pay pigs that will wander i'm manifesting pay pigs will wander over to azura's stream
for her birthday
And just give that beautiful woman money so she can move out
Can you hex yourself?
uh
technically yes
Because like
If you mess something up or you disrespect like a spirit that you're working with or something like it can kind of
Blow back at you. I don't like
Hexing because I just feel like it's like negative like I don't really want to send negative energy
Like there's some people out there. I'm like witch talk that'll be like, oh if you do something bad
It's gonna come back at you three times. No
No, that's like that's like a wicked thing and I'm not wicked
You can get anti-wealth right now send all of your money to she being you have to deal with that in any more
Magic. Thank you foo
Send some send some to fuwa too
Forfeit all of your moral possession to the goddess azura
Can you do one for success for my little brother? Oh, that's so sweet of you
Oh keep keep holding that intention
Keep holding that intention and something so maybe something won't go to come come from it
Okay, it looks like it's self-love and growth ladies and gentlemen. So that's what we will be doing
You
Self-love and growth carom mean haram karambita
So we're doing self-love self-growth. Oh
Who's talking shit? Who's talking shit?
This candle's going crazy. It's also melting very fast. This one's been fine. This one I got um
In a special place made by somebody. Um, and they rolled it with like herbs and stuff
um
She be I found and kept a cool green rock when I was digging around my yard a few years ago
Does that mean something? It's probably just a cool rock. I'm so sorry
We can't
I'm not the dead name dead naming mercy
Oh
Sometimes the cigar is just a cigar. It's the beautiful stuff. Stop wait. Can I
Where is it I can't
There we go. I offer you a rose
Will you take it?
Will you take the rose?
Wine wine wine rose
See now it works. I don't understand that
Hear me clicking away
Haram will you accept this rose and move forward on the bachelorette? You will be
My immersion. Okay, so I have some drawers. Let me grab a drawer
And I literally got these drawers from s see there's a bunch of drawers
Let's see. I need one with a good cork in it
You
Oh, do you guys want to see my favorite deck?
I got this deck a while ago. This is the first deck I ever purchased
This is the deck my mom like freaked out about because she saw it and she wanted me to throw it away because my parents are very Christian
They're called soul cards. They're very popular
What the I don't know if you'll be able to see them
But they're so gorgeous they have like roses hold on
Three two one flashbang
They have like roses and stuff
They're like really pretty minimalistic gold
This is the Wheel of Fortune. Oh, that's good. It was in reverse though, so maybe not so good. I didn't shuffle these though
Oh, we got the devil, but isn't that gorgeous though? Like those look like good tacks, you know, I can see someone get like getting that as a tat
I
Have a lot of decks
I'm pulling all our kana cards when I'm going through this deck. I'm just
Going through that's so funny. How about what about the next one? The next one's our kana card. It's not, okay?
It's a womb tattoo. Yeah, they actually do look like womb tattoos
But this is really pretty. It's my favorite deck
Yeah, I have one, two, three
Ordex? What deck is that?
Oh, wait. No, I have two oracle decks and three tarot decks. In fact, I will get the oracle deck out
Guys, I had, I had, I had
Ice cream today because it was hot outside and I think I got poop, but it's fine. Um, I have this oracle star seat
I don't, so I don't believe
You can google what a star seat is. I do not
Subscribe to that belief system
But I like
bit
Calm down
Thank you
Stop
Whoever's talking shit, your mom's a hoe
Um, but these are really cool. I'll probably use these during the
Tarot reading today because they have a lot of cool self-reflection stuff the blue flame
This one's fine. This one's freaking out
No, it's not that this is a protection candle and it's telling me people are wishing me harm right now
I don't blame them
And then I have a monology manifestation one. I just this is my most recent one that I got
Oh
Exodia obliterate the aunties who will beat them
Okay, so
Where oh here you are
I'm going to cleanse the jar
So I have some um
dragon's blood incense
And I'm gonna dab a little bit of florida water. It's a spirit of the tomagotchi 100%
And there's like by the way, there's like no rhyme or like
Like you don't have to do if you see this and you're just like, oh, I have to do it this way
No, this is what I found to be the best for me
You don't have to follow what I'm doing to make your own
You can kind of just go with your own intuition a lot of stuff is intuition based
Dragon's blood smells so good
It's a perk exactly. That's why I like this because it's just it's a personal experience
I don't even know this will work. This is usually for candles. Oh, it worked kind of no
So I'm just gonna
So normally when you cleanse something you want to cleanse it with fire, you know all the elements earth air fire
um
So I'll be putting like some salt in this
Or you put some like the florida water this is like smoking like the fires in the air in the air essentially
And I just feel like this into a bit a little bit more
Mmm, this smells absolutely delicious
I forgot what I had this year for
Oh, this is to put on the
Thingamabob this is gonna be put on the cork
to seal it in purple
Just vibes
Do you believe in the 3am stuff? What is the 3am stuff?
Wind water heart go planet or like if anybody remembers like toy box
Earth wind water and fire
Can't get in the way when I'm running to you
Because I would go through stormy weather just to tell you how much I love you
Okay, so we got that
So we're doing self-love. I love self-love. So this is a this will be a personal
So and I I literally have some rose quartz right here. This will be the centerpiece
Oh, I kind of like it if I just stick it in the center of the eye that feels really right
Um, okay
Oh
The witching hour
Oh, okay
Oh, I wake up at 3am or 3 3 3 all the time like
If I wake up in the middle of the night, it's at those numbers and I'm just like, huh neat goes back to sleep
Like it's fine
I want to do a 3am challenge because those are dumb. I don't fuck with spirits, you know
Um
They don't fuck with me. I don't fuck with them
My rug is getting messed up
I
Yeah, I'm not doing station
3am I did one of those little games and then the Elmo doll came to life
So I'm just taking out some stuff
You know
I like using Himalayan pink salt because again pink love self love. I love that so much
Am I not doing something over here?
So I'll put a little bit of Himalayan pink salt in there for the earth component
also for like some added
Protection stuff. I need to get some more Himalayan pink. So that's a good
I do a little bit more
Perfect nice little layer
You know, you know qualms in there
What did I just do okay, I'm like what did I just do with the cork for this?
3am looked at myself in the mirror and the mirror image moved, but so did I
Calling among us at 3am amogus
Amogus at 3am
I
I am out of I used to have rose quartz. So I have like
A little bit of rope like I had it in like one of these little tiny ones
But I'm out. So that's a bummer
However
Can I fit?
I have
Rose quartz. Will that fit in there? Oh
Will this fit?
Well, this is peach quartz. Oh it will. Oh my god. Okay. So you guys can have this cute peach quartz
It actually kind of looks like a heart
Oh
In a way not really, but it will fit in the jar. So I'll put that in there
Get in there
Okay, it just fit a second ago. I just put it in the wrong way
Oh, no, I already messed this up. That's a bad sign bros. It's also just I can't get this out because my nails
If you squint hard enough, it's close
Oh my god, why did I like I love my nails, but I can't pick up anything
Hold on I need to get something to help me let me get this out because it's like it's like um
I can't pick it up. It just keeps falling out slipping out of my nails
Oh
Oh, where'd that go?
Oh, does that point perfectly when I charted a different one?
Oh, there.
Boy things.
It's in there.
I don't know if you can see.
It's like the big giant rock.
That was from my personal collection, that little peach quartz.
I got that. I forget when I got that little peach quartz.
Okay.
I'm just shaping heart, but a heart nonetheless.
And you know, I feel like there's a lesson there.
There's a lesson there.
If you feel like you're like not worthy of love,
or if you're a little misshapen,
there is always, you will always find a way to fit somewhere.
You are, you will fit.
You're fine. You're all right.
I'm going to do a little bit of amethyst
for the crown chocker for the self growth.
I don't need, can I go to a cool rock fund?
I haven't really shopped for any gems or stones in a long time.
I actually haven't gone to my metaphysical shop in quite a bit.
How many, hold on, how many?
How many?
What's the word?
Starts to see not how many channels in a heart.
How many?
How many chambers?
Oh my God.
There are four chambers.
That's right.
I could remember if there was five.
Okay.
So I'm going to put one for each chamber because I've already put three in.
So I'll put a fourth in.
I like me some numbers.
I'll put a fourth.
You know what?
Let's throw in some adventuring for luck.
Put one piece of adventuring.
So this is adventuring.
I can never pronounce it right.
It's like a light green stone.
Now we know how good job you're in jeopardy.
And I'm going to put a little bit of honey to sweeten up our lives.
I need something to get the honey out though.
I think now we'll get like a chopstick.
I think I can drizzle that in from the chopstick.
Hi, Boobie.
Hi, handsome boy.
I just frickin' tricked or something.
I'm okay.
Show cat?
I don't even know where Boobie just went.
He walked by me and then he was like, later, dude.
Oh my God.
I knocked you over your heart.
Oh, no, no, no.
Don't fall with my heart.
I wonder if I'll take you home.
I'll let you settle in for love and health.
We're going to sweeten up our self-love.
We're going to sweeten up our lives in growth.
Mmm, delicious.
You know, honey never goes bad.
It like kills whatever bacteria and fungus tries to get inside of it.
It's great.
Honey can preserve human bodies.
Yes, Mero.
Hi, Mero.
Yep, it's very, very cool.
Honey doesn't go bad and can be used as an antiseptic because it's too sugary of very little oxygen.
Truth.
All right, let's see you guys.
I don't know if you guys can see how crazy that flame is getting.
That one's chilling.
That one's...
I just need to focus.
It looks like...
I can see it getting brighter.
Someone's not happy.
Did I just accidentally box myself?
I don't know.
Your tower decks look so pretty.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mero.
Flashbang out.
Flame is working over time.
I'm like, I think it's just because the wick is too long to be honest with you at that point.
This one's fine.
That one's not doing so well.
It looks like it's close to the phone, but it's literally not.
I'm sticking my hand in front of it.
It's fine.
Just save that close to the soundproofing.
Do you want me to move it?
Do you want me to put it right in front of the camera?
Flashbang.
Whoa, that looks so cool.
What the hell?
The wick also split in two.
Everything has him, and now it's calming down.
I think because the person feels called out.
The wick is split in two.
This person is torn.
They don't know why they hate, but they do.
Now it's calming down.
Now this one's getting longer.
My spirits are agreeing.
Show pedicure.
I already did earlier.
The frenzied flame.
I can hear the haters via the candle.
It looks like it's going to go out soon, which is very interesting.
I think the person-
I saw that on my screen.
Slowly tip.
I'm going down real in timbre.
Okay, we're fine.
You're okay.
It's okay, sweetie.
You're fine.
Are you okay?
You have some, have some quarts.
Have some quarts.
It actually jumped.
I saw it on my screen slowly tipping.
I'm trying to get the balance.
Snorting rocks.
Hell yeah, brother.
All right.
So we got that.
We got that.
It's funny because when I mentioned I wanted to do a spell jar, a self-love came up a lot.
And so that's why everything's purple because purple is very spiritual.
It's very like higher enlightenment.
It has to do a lot with like, I don't know, personally for me growth.
So that's why I got purple.
Everything's purple, purple, purple, purple.
My outfit is red, but I just didn't feel like changing it.
I thought I would blend it into the background if I did purple.
The spirit is in the room.
No, it's not a spirit.
This is a physical representation of anybody who is wishing me harm.
This is the spirit.
Spirit's chilling.
Spirit's been just hanging out, having a great time.
Tough kid must have felt one.
My God.
I haven't touched the Tamagotchi, by the way.
I looked at it.
Why did nobody tell me the chat was like not working for the last like hour?
Why did nobody say anything?
Guys.
You thought I knew?
You did?
Oh.
Awkward.
Too locked in of content.
It's from before stream.
Wait, you're not scuffed?
I dropped the camera several times and the chat wasn't working.
I'm very scuffed.
We move.
We go.
Sorry, Vod Watchers.
You're not going to be able to see what people are talking about.
You're just going to hear me ramble.
I'll try to pay attention to that more often.
Okay.
So you got that.
So I have some lavender.
And you see lavender is good for like calm just in general.
It's good for like calming, relaxation.
I got everywhere I got this from.
You can't really tell what it says for protection.
The label.
Tamagotchi alive barely.
It was, it kept growing up ugly.
So I kept ignoring it.
So I'm throw some lavender in there.
Lavender for protecting ourselves as we go on our spiritual journey and grow.
We're also going to do some peppermint.
Poor second child.
We're going to do some peppermint to ward off any negativity.
And peppermint is good for like health and stuff.
Or just like mint in general.
So jazz, I have some Jasmine here.
Jasmine is used for love and friendship and sweetness.
And so this will help, you know, sweeten up our relationships a little bit.
Heck is this.
It's witchcraft motherfucker.
I already have a child.
It's Fia.
She's my baby.
She's literally a baby.
I say, I tell Fia, you ready for the high chair?
And then I stick, I sit her upright on the couch and I start feeding her.
And I give her a little bib.
This piece is too long.
Boomi is my child.
Raina is also my child.
Raina is the eldest child.
So this is what we got so far.
Oh, let me turn on the light.
Flash bang.
So you got some honey.
You got some peach courts.
You got some Himalayan pink salt.
We got some lavender.
You got some Jasmine.
Feeling good.
You have a little bit of amethyst for each chamber of the heart.
Everything's about like kind of like symbolism to be honest with you.
That's why I like, I usually do stuff like by numbers.
Let's do some rosemary for strength and protection.
Spirit's feeling pretty good.
See that candle kind of going.
It's feeling, it's feeling pretty happy.
I'm doing this.
I can tell.
Honey interacting with the salt.
Probably.
They're chilling.
They're eating each other.
Rosemary.
Yeah.
All about belief.
It's all about intention.
There's no hard rules.
You make it what it is.
What's tiger's eye and black onyx?
Black onyx is like, usually like, I say black obsidian and black onyx are like,
grounding and protection.
Tiger's eye.
I actually, I'm not drawn to tiger's eye.
So I don't really know a lot about tiger's eye.
I know my, one of my friends loves tiger's eye.
So I usually will buy her like tiger's eye stuff.
Usually I believe that's for like clairvoyance stuff.
I can't really recall.
Just Google it.
Go on Pinterest.
Witchy cotton bum.
Can you remove a curse in my life?
Twice people who I joked about dying nearly do.
Did I upset the fey?
Oh no.
I don't fuck with the fey.
I don't know.
The fact that you know who the fey are and you want, you acknowledge them.
You've probably done something to piss them off.
If you're specifically bringing them up, then.
Tiger's eye is a very pretty stone.
My personal favorite.
You can see it right here is labradorite.
Labradorite has a really pretty flash.
Hold on.
I can't, it's, it's a type of felt spar.
I'll show it to you.
Let me just turn on the light again.
Yippee flashbang.
A friend gave me this.
You can see the really gorgeous flash.
I love labradorite.
So gorgeous.
What are the fey?
Google it.
Google exists and is free for everyone.
Did I, did I ever tell you guys about my, my, my run-in with the fey?
So.
I remember.
So this is when I was first like researching the fey.
And learning about them.
Cause I was, I was learning more about my Irish heritage.
Cause I am Irish on my mother's side.
And so I was in like, you know, fey are huge.
Like the, the, the fey folk are very, very integral to Ireland.
And, um, so I was like doing research.
I was talking about it a lot.
I was kind of, I was kind of, I was kind of like,
I was like doing research.
I was talking about it a lot.
I was kind of, I wasn't being disrespectful per se,
but I was, I was bringing too much attention up to them.
Um, and then one day I walked outside, um, just to hang out outside just
because it was like summer, spring day or whatever the heck I can remember.
And I'm walking around.
I am kind of, I usually will pick stuff from my mother's garden to like,
all I used to when I lived with my parents to like put in my stuff.
And, um, cause I know my spiritual team, they love fresh flowers from like,
that was their favorite thing is fresh flowers from my mom's garden.
Anytime I visit my mom, I'll bring back flowers for them.
And, um, so, uh, I'm walking around and picking up stuff and I go,
so there's a big, huge, giant maple tree in my child and home's backyard.
Huge, huge, huge, huge, um, maple tree.
Um, and I used to like, I used, I love that maple tree.
I would climb it all the time.
I did like so much like, cause I'm an only child.
I would like play so much all the time over there.
I had a swing on it.
It was great.
I love that tree.
It's awesome.
I had a nice big backyard growing up.
I was very thankful for that cause I spent a lot of my time outside.
And, um, like it was eight hours of wolf quests and wolf role playing.
And then I would go outside the next day for eight hours.
That's how my life was.
And, um, the day that I was kind of like, I'll just get to the point.
I go to the base of the tree and there is a mouse cleanly cut in half.
Where you walk outside.
There's a mouse cleanly cut in half head over here and trails back body over here.
Perfectly laid out heart and trails, all that stuff guts.
I'm looking around.
I'm looking to see like, did a hawk drop this?
Did a cat get to it?
But no, the body was laid out and it was on a, cause there's like, there's like, um,
you know how like, obviously there'll be rocks in the ground.
So they're like, in the base of the tree, there was this giant rock and it was almost
like a flat, like rock at the base of the tree that was like among the roots.
And it was laid perfectly there.
My candle is freaking out cause it knows what I'm talking about.
Perfectly there.
And you remember the story?
And I was like, oh, and I just knew it was like a fucking threat.
I was like, no, thank you, no, thank you.
I'm so sorry.
Um, by the way, if never accept a gift from the Fay cause they'll want something in return
or, um, by the way, um, so if it was a gift, if it was like a warning, I left it there.
I left it there.
Um, I immediately went inside.
I grabbed a little saucer, like a little plate or like a little, like a glass cup of milk,
put some honey in it, put a little bread out, um, like a sign.
And then I left and I came back the next day.
Mouse was gone.
Like I had never, ever been there.
Like there wasn't like guts and entrails or like blood stains or like some like sort of
like on the rock.
Like it was, I remember going to my mom and showing her this and she was so disturbed.
Um, I was like, mom, do you think a cat did this?
Like a neighborhood cat?
She's like, I don't know why, but I feel really bad about that.
And when my Christian mom says she feels really bad about something, then I know something's up.
You're asking what they're just saying.
Hi, maybe, maybe, um, the next day, uh, the milk was gone.
The thing remained.
And you know, there's like ants and stuff drinking like, like eating a little remnant.
So the honey in there, uh, the bread was gone.
There was no ants on the board.
There was no crumbs.
No crumbs were left.
No crumbs.
And then I know, and then, and then I saw, I was telling my friends this story.
And then when I got home, my mom's like the weirdest thing happened.
And I'm like, what?
And she's just like, so my parents have like a ring camera.
Um, just so they can keep an eye on stuff.
Like if there's like, you know, cause they live in a kind of busy road or whatever.
And somebody's broken into the house before when I was younger.
That's another story I'll tell another time.
And my mom's like, it was really weird.
Uh, I was looking at the ring camera.
There was this flash of light in the camera feed cut off.
And when I went to go look to see what had happened, she went and looked at the ring camera.
The ring camera was melted.
Mind you, there's nothing around that would like shine a light to like melt the camera.
There was like, there's like two little pronged, like melted lines.
There's nothing or there's no, it was not, it didn't short.
My mom checked the inside of the camera.
The inside was impeccable.
The outside was melted with nothing nearby that could have caused still, you know, I, I'm not
a dumbass.
I will think of rational explanations for things like, Oh, maybe it was a bug or maybe it was a cat that got it.
Maybe it was a hawk that dropped it, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, like the, but the mouse.
Um, and then I was sitting and I'm like, maybe there was a piece of glass that like cast a light.
And I'm like, no, maybe there's like a wire.
And I'm like, no, maybe there was something.
And I'm like, I can't think my parents couldn't come with, come up with any explanation for it.
And you don't see anybody walking by the camera.
You don't see anything happening around the time before and after it like cut in and out.
Nobody walks up, nobody like comes near, nobody shoots anything at it.
Like it was, and it wasn't like, and it wasn't, it was only the outside.
It was so weird.
But after that, I was like, okay, I'm just not going to talk about it anymore.
And now me and me and the fair cool, we're chill, we're chill.
I learned about them, they learn about me.
I get, I leave them alone.
And now my mom, it's so funny.
I know they love my mom's garden because my mom has so much fucking fairy stuff around.
My mom's like a green which doesn't even know it.
My mom is freakishly good at growing things.
She has a lot of, damn the fade did not like the camera.
They did not.
You laugh like it's a casual.
Well, I just have to laugh it off, you know.
And yeah, one encounter was enough.
The second one I was terrified.
My mom has like lots of little fairy houses like in her garden.
And they're so, and my mom has like bird houses and stuff.
It's so cute.
My mom is a beautiful garden.
She does such a good job.
Yeah, it's probably just Brad being a silly goose.
They're telling stories about stories about them now though.
That's a good point.
I was thinking of that as I was saying it.
The candle is flickering a bit, but I kind of, I think it was more like a mutual understanding.
And like, again, I was kind of being disrespectful when I told the story the first time.
I'm like, can you believe this silly stuff that happened, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And so it was just like a warning.
It was just kind of like respect us or respect you sort of thing.
Um, yeah, they're chill now.
They're chill now.
There's nothing has happened since aliens could be aliens.
Aliens.
Okay, let's finish this.
But how much time has passed 733?
Oh my God.
Many will not survive the winter.
It was me.
It was even of you guys.
Ancient aliens.
Um, okay.
So back to this.
Let's see.
Everyone's married yet?
Let's do.
Okay.
I'm going to put in some cinnamon for healing.
I never watched the ancient magus bride.
I wanted to watch that put in some cinnamon is very, very good for you.
This in general, a lot of the stuff I'm putting in literally has this like normal anti-inflammatory
like medicinal properties.
Like that's why tea is so good for you.
I wish Americans drank more tea to be honest.
I wish we were like Britain and China and Japan and Korea and India in terms of drinking tea.
Yeah, don't don't do the cinnamon challenge.
Those are places that drink a lot of tea.
What can I tell you?
Coffee is good.
I'm going to put some star anise in there for some good luck.
I feel like it's missing.
Oh, rose petals.
Which Toma, I pulled the tower upright the other day.
I generally, I wish I did I take a picture of the reading?
I hope I did.
I have to look at it because I want you to look at the cards.
Did I?
I don't know because I couldn't take a picture.
Oh, wait.
No, no, no.
I didn't shuffle these yet.
The cards are actually on top.
The ones that I pulled.
I'll show you guys really.
I'm fine.
I don't know what the tower was about to be honest with you.
I'm okay.
I dropped my keys down an elevator shaft, but like it's fine.
Like I'll get them back eventually.
Tower upright is not particularly good.
Here.
I'll show you.
So I pulled these cards.
I know it's these ones.
Nope.
It was.
No, it wasn't the wait.
Wasn't the fool?
No.
Because the fool was on the bottom is this one.
Yes.
Okay.
So I pulled the queen of cups.
I pulled page of cups.
Um, is that upright or was that?
I'm trying to remember if it's reverse or not.
Page of cups in reverse tower upright and then 10 of cups upright.
It was very ice.
I generally still don't know what it means.
Sorry.
This is the bottom of the deck.
That's why it's on top because I was showing you guys.
I don't even change.
Yeah.
I was just like, what does that mean?
So you guys can't see shit.
So queen of cups.
I feel like that's representing me.
Page of cups.
Um, so I feel, I haven't really been like, I haven't really been practicing.
Um, so I feel like that was telling me like get back into my practice, which is kind of
why I wanted to do the submarine.
Then I got the tower.
I love it.
How it looks.
I love the tower.
And then I have 10 of cups.
Maybe that's OBS was sitting while it was.
It is mercury is in Gatorade.
So technology is not reliable amongst those times.
Um, but the tower card would not tower is major sudden change.
I don't think OBS shitting the bed would do that.
Maybe the tower comes with it.
She looks like he's going to tell me something.
I could take a stab later.
Please do.
Please do Toma.
Cause I was like, I, I read these immediately and I was like, huh.
And then another, other than the thought box and I'm like, I need to tell Toma, but I kept forgetting.
Okay.
Let me.
This needs a little bit more rose petals.
That's what we need.
We need some rose petals in Hibiscus, baby girl rose petals in Hibiscus.
Let me grab that.
Tell Mercury to get out of the Gatorade.
Please don't need that.
It's sometimes changes drastic and uncomfortable.
We'll leave it at things in happiness.
That's essentially, um, what the tower card is.
It's like sudden change.
I can't get this out.
Um, but it's necessary.
And I'm someone who's averse to change.
I feel like that's just reminding me, like I need to embrace change or I'm not going to go anywhere.
Cause I, I, I generally have something called an adjustment disorder and I'm not shitting you.
I'm not trying to be quirky girl right now.
I literally was diagnosed with something called adjustment disorder and changes very hard for me.
Um, so like adjusting to being a Vtuber has to be,
adjusting to being a Vtuber has been very interesting because this is my full-time job.
So I think maybe just like, I know this has been a big change to stick with it.
Would a pack of plain white paper with the names of the cards written on them still work for tarot?
Or is a fancy design also part of the magic?
Uh, yeah.
It's like skins equals wins and CS go and Valorant.
Uh, you have to have nice car.
No.
Uh, you can honestly, you can buy like a normal writer weight tarot deck for like 10 bucks.
I like them as a physical store.
So.
You should be fine.
Unless you, if you don't got money, you can try the 70, 78, I think.
I can't remember.
Cards in the deck.
Pay to win tarot readings.
Once you get, once you prestige, you get better cards.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
You can really, cause I remember I use, uh, I forget what I, cause you can use like a normal deck of playing cards.
Technically.
Uh, you just won't have the major arcana.
Um, cause you can use the suits as like club, yeah, club, swords, you know, lawns, hearts, cup, like the, the coincide.
It's all about you with your intuition.
Exactly.
It's homo.
Level 99 tarot boss.
Level one psychic level 99 tarot boss.
I sesame flash.
Yes.
Toma has done a silly reading for me with the Sesame Street, uh, cards.
It was like, I remember showing me those.
I just pulled a mint tarot deck.
How much is it worth?
It's like you, you like, it's like factory new tarot deck.
Oh my God.
A, a game that's like CS go, except it's cards that you throw at people and you're like fucking gambit and you got to like.
That can't, that can't look out bigger.
It is wiggling so much.
I think my, I think my spirits are very amused by that.
Um, Hearthstone, Hearthstone, but make it CS go.
Be alert tarot deck when that would be so cool.
If someone, I think someone was working on like a Vtuber tarot deck because I remember seeing like, like iron mouse and stuff.
Do, do, do.
Hold on, I'm just reading something.
Okay.
That's fine.
Well, I was knocked out over.
Yep.
Turn that off for the ambi.
This looks so cool.
I'm not going to lie to you.
This looks so nifty.
My mall is on the other side because I had to flip my model.
So it doesn't look like I'm like looking the other direction.
Got my four of cups to supreme plus blue eyes.
She beat attack mode.
Is it iron mouse?
Yeah.
No, iron mouse.
I think someone like used her as like a sort of, um, in like muse for tarot deck series.
And I, it was pretty cool.
All right.
So actually let me turn the light back on three, two, one, flashbang.
So this is the, the jar.
Again, we have a honey, Himalayan salt, peach, um, quartz.
Okay.
Uh, lavender, Jasmine, cinnamon, star anise, hibiscus, rose petals, rosemary.
Yippee.
That looks pretty good.
I want to eat it.
I don't recommend that.
The artist is, artists make the tarot deck series of the show, Joe's and artist names.
Oh yeah.
I think that's them.
Ooh.
Hi.
Hi, anybody new?
If you're just wandering in.
La la la.
Okay.
So now we'll seal this with a kiss.
I'm going to give it a little kiss as little kisses for you.
We'll kiss for you on the top because I want you to love yourself.
I want you to grow.
I want you to be amazing and everybody does too.
Everybody look to the person left to you in this chat and tell them how amazing they are
and that they'll do amazing things.
Okay.
Right now.
And I'm going to seal this.
I'm going to put this in here.
It has a little bit of the ash from my incense in there.
So I'm just giving you a cheer.
We go light this up like it's dynamite.
I haven't met many people into Wicca or what you're doing.
Sorry, I don't care.
Those who have met are really cool people.
Yeah.
No, I'm not.
I'm not Wiccan.
I'm just me.
You're amazing friend.
Yeah.
Everybody.
Everybody tell each other how amazing they are and cool.
Man, I searched the Vaude and found no pedicure toes show off.
Please help.
Did you really go back and look for the Vaude?
It's really there.
I don't know what the timestamp is.
I'm sorry, bro.
Please.
Can you burn?
I need you to melt.
You have to accidentally melt it on the thing.
I should have cut this.
I think I have a pink candle.
That's not the first time I've done that.
Can I cut this?
I do this instead.
Oh, you know what I actually have?
I actually have ceiling wax that I bought and I don't know why I bought it, but I was
like, let me buy this.
And I think I know why now.
I literally went to the store when I was getting the wood beads for the witch stuff.
And I literally got just a, I don't know why I got this.
What's ceiling wax?
Sealing like we're sealing something.
We're closing it.
Maybe you got it for what?
Why?
Who am I doing what?
Am I just going to burn myself with wax by myself?
That's boring.
No.
The wax is dripping from this candle.
I think she be falls into the Empress card roll, but she's going to involve into something
more.
I identify with the, um, what's it called?
I'm going to use the gold wax.
I identify with the magician.
Oh, because I have been told I am a master.
Um, there's a, oh my guys, there's a freaking, I couldn't remember what the, it's a bee.
It's a bee and a flower.
And I put honey in it.
Guys, this was meant.
That's so funny.
Do you want the bee or do you want the flower?
Dark magician for letters to pen pals.
You want to be, you want a busy bee?
All right.
BB bee.
BB.
I don't know.
I'm just going to, it's going to be like a really weird looking bee on top, but you
know, we got it.
All right.
Let's use the gold cause gold for that wealth, baby.
You got a little purple in there for stuff.
All right.
Why is this like slanted?
Well, cause there's already wax that have melted in here from a long time ago.
I should probably cut this.
I'm nothing to cut it with.
Wait.
I have a knife.
This is very, this is very GRIK.
I use this for cutting boxes.
Okay.
I don't know.
It's working.
I don't know if this is working.
I think it is.
It's not.
This is not sharp enough.
I don't feel like getting up to get scissors.
Let me go away.
Mommy's cutting stuff.
Mommy doesn't want to accidentally cut you.
Please don't jump on my lap.
You look like you're looking at it.
I'm halfway there, guys.
Careful.
She's got him.
What's that?
A knife.
No.
Again, my spiritual team is amused.
The flame be dancing.
Why is this like, stay?
Why is he doing that?
I did it.
We gonna light this up like it's dying.
Oh, my.
Boomi's playing with something under my desk.
What are you playing with?
Boomi, don't go in the trash.
What are you doing?
Hi, handsome.
Did you bring your spring over here?
You did.
Why did you do that?
I'm not gonna throw it because then you're gonna want to bring it back.
Bring it back now, y'all.
I'm off this time.
Did I cut it too short?
Whoa, this is so fancy looking.
It's like I've never had like actual wax before.
I've only ever used like candles to seal stuff.
This is gonna be so gorgeous to look at.
This might take a while.
Don't you burn out on me?
I think I cut it too short.
This is so fancy, guys.
I'm gonna make it so dribbles.
A little bit of dribble in there.
I can't tell what it looks like from the side.
Okay, I think that's properly sealed.
I love that it's sealed with a gold.
Oh, it's so pretty.
Ooh, that candle's going crazy.
Did you guys see that over there?
Someone is falling apart right now.
Someone's sad.
Who is it?
Who's very sad?
Okay, let's put the bee.
Now sit on it.
Making it dribble a little.
Dribble for the aesthetic, you know.
And bees are a hive and they take care of each other.
And that's what we're gonna do.
We're gonna all take care of each other.
Mm-hmm.
Yep, yep, yep.
Yep, yep.
Yippie-dee-dub.
Ooh, spooky.
Flashbang.
Okay, I turned it down to the lightest setting,
so it still looks on beyond so we can still see what's going on.
Crying in the club.
Hey guys, minor problem.
How do you stick a 5-inch long 1-inch dinosaur in there?
It cannot be damaged from wax.
What? That looks so cool.
Yo, yo.
It's a little bee.
I should have moved it down, but it's still really cool.
If it could focus.
Focusing it.
What the hell is going on outside?
Anyways, the bee is there.
You can see it.
Spell jar.
Ladies and gentlemen, the spell jar has been made.
The intention has been sealed and set.
And now it's going to go on my altar.
That's it.
What do you guys think?
What do you...
Successful self-love and growth?
You know, I think it's pretty good.
I think it's pretty nice.
I don't know why the...
It's so yellow.
Because of the saturation I put on it.
We did it.
Yeah.
Ice emo.
We did it.
Looks like claws gripping.
Oh my God, you're right.
That's kind of cool.
All right, I'm going to put that up there.
That was pretty cool.
What the hell?
I'm so happy I got this.
I don't know.
Get back in the box, bitch.
Where am I going to put this?
I have to find a place to put this.
Maybe I'll put in the box with my jars.
My jar box.
Jar, maybe.
That's really cool.
I'm so happy I got that.
Now to go Campbell.
No, that's...
It wasn't a wealth or luck thing.
It was just self-love and growth.
Okay.
What am I doing?
What the hell are we?
I can catch some super full moon.
Yeah, we're getting that super full moon power.
We love it when you put this stuff away.
It's going to be fun cleaning this up later.
Okay.
Put that up here.
Thank you very much.
And then the remnants I used for a spell I throw outside.
I return it back to the earth.
So I'm going to go through this upside.
I'm going to go throw it off my balcony and hope that it hits somebody in the head.
Get blessed.
Get blessed for real, for real.
Eat them.
I'm good.
I don't think so.
What are you doing here?
Oh, you napped it.
Oh, you can get hurt.
It's so pretty on that one.
Nothing like the door frames don't fit.
My doors don't close properly.
Okay.
All right, folks, we are going to take a quick intervention.
Intermission so I can use the rest room.
I'll be back in five minutes.
I'm going to put on my BRB screen.
Make sure you get up, stretch your legs, hydrate, get a snacky poo.
Then we will be getting into the tarot.
I will pin a message saying how much the tarot will be reading.
The tarot will be and what to put in to your request.
So donate $5 and what your question is.
I'll probably only take a couple of people, not a lot.
We'll do it for the next hour.
And I think that sounds pretty reasonable.
What do you think?
Yeah.
Okay.
Five.
Die.
Four.
Five.
Th.
off and put everything back on it took me a moment and then I had to flip Fia over because she's a
pancake. Hope you didn't miss me for too long. Oh who is so okay someone's really sad right now.
Who's sad? Talk to me. Talk to me girly pop. Who's sad? Who does the brain worms? Because this flame
looks so pathetic right now. It looks so sad it's like you can't see but it's like bent over like
it's sad like it's sad Keanu Reeves dripping down sad. I'm gonna have to replace that candle soon
it's gonna go out. Don't worry it doesn't mean people are done or I just like
heck somebody or anything don't worry. Wait you didn't leave the flame on right? What do you mean?
You were sad I was gone. Maybe. I mean I'm panicking a bit.
Me lost without the toes. Okay let me put my headphone in. Can we eat the candle? You can try.
I can I can break you off a little piece. Here you go let me.
That's for you girly pop. Wanna want a snack? Come on take a little bite.
Oh oh oh oh okay oh oh you actually ate it. Well what can you do? What can you do? Take a sip of my water.
Ah delicious. All right I can't rub my hands together with these things on.
Let me get into the most optimum position. This is too close.
I think it was better where it was. How did I have this before? I had it like this.
I had it like see it's on fire. It looks like it but I assure you it's not.
All right just like that. We're gonna do it just like that and I'm kidding I'm just gonna keep it the way it was.
I don't know how I did this before. How I did the terrarium the first time.
I am going to move this first of all. Trying not to knock stuff down.
Just get this stuff out of the way. Labradorite. Labradorite's for me.
Okay let me put up the terms and conditions.
I'm sorry grounding myself again. I'm gonna cleanse again.
I will probably do Icy's tarot like for her by herself. Um like personally send her something
because I'm not gonna read her tarot when she's not here.
Unless she's here. Icy are you with us? No she's she's she's knocked out.
Um let me do deals. So
I should make like 50 bucks. Don't ask why I'm holding a rose.
First five people to send me 50 dollars. No I'm kidding. No no no no no no.
Read my ratot. Based ratot.
Okay.
Your reimbursement went through so it's all profit now. Why are you holding a rose?
All right.
I'm gonna do a general reading for all of us. Don't you worry.
Then I'll do specific what the fuck is with the camera. Then I'll do specific readings for peoples.
Whoa. She's crazy. Ratatouille. Ratatouille then.
Let me pull up stream last stream elements. I should have specified through stream elements.
Whoa.
I didn't I walked away. Why are you tipping me when I walk away?
Boss your hot topic reimbursement just came through. Turns out we compensate unity ring
purchases. Thank you. Thank you Dr. P.
Flowerhead. Whoa whoa whoa people.
Can I get a reading for my future? I know weird spot where I'm doing everything. I can
define a good job and better my future with everyone telling me I'm doing fine. Yeah I
still feel like I'm not doing enough. Sorry this is too broad. Sinus cancer. Thank you.
Capricorn. How will the back half of my year go? Okay so like the next like the next few months or
two. What do you mean?
Sagittarius. How can I better manage jealous feelings? Oh interesting. Why are you jealous?
God damn. All right so we got we got Flowerhead, Rifle Chaos, Doki, anybody else? Any other takers?
Steal your mom's credit card to get a get a psychic reading from your favorite Oshi ladies and gentlemen.
Anonymous. I'm a Scorpio. I got divorced at the end of last year. What's it? Oh sweetheart. Oh
oh I just got hit with a wave of emotion from from your spiritual team. Holy
shit. Oh that was rough. That was a rough divorce. Oh shit it was not amicable at all I could tell.
Okay okay stop tipping. I'm cutting it off. I'm cutting it off. No more tips. No more tips.
Remove. I was donating a super chat. Well it's stream elements is in the description.
Is super amicable we still live together? Okay then I was wrong.
I see like I can say when I'm wrong. I can say when I'm full of shit. I don't know why I got a wave of
emotion but something's painful you know.
Emily. Hi Shibi. I would like a reading which is an overview of September. I'm a Pisces. Okay Emily
could do that for you. No one's special. Aquarius. Recently I made a major financial decision not
I don't want to. Can you change your question because I don't want to give you stuff on money
because I don't like doing money stuff. As you can see I said they had a hard
divorce and that wasn't true so who knows if I'm correct.
You're from your own divorce.
Well maybe that belonged to somebody else. Was it you Dr. P? Did you have a non amicable divorce?
So sad.
Okay maybe it was you because you donated first. Who knows?
Shibi do I bet on all red or black? All red.
Emily, just big telling of future. Yes the spirits are not very good at timing the
market. Someone on the other side of the world dealing with the rough divorce. Why do I feel
like I've been seen? Again when you do this you don't have to believe in it.
I'm not always right. You can take it with you although it's funny because when I do the cards
I'm always right. Going off of my own personal intuition I'm not always right. My gut feelings
are not correct most of the time. But yeah let's let's let's chat with the cards instead.
Red. Life savings all in red. Yes. It's still staying cheat sheet. Okay that might have been you then.
Okay let's do that. Cool. I'll do the sixth person that snuck in because I feel bad. They
like don't need it at the same time as um as I was reading stuff.
Sketchy witch gives you a tarot reading ASMR.
All right so first I'm gonna do a general reading for everybody.
Beep beep beep beep beep beep.
Me clings my thick. Let me clings my thick.
This wasn't really helpful. Where's my lighter because the little other thing wasn't really
working. Where did I put it? Am I blind? You guys see it on my desk? I'm blind.
I
Ever get where I put things like the majority of the time
Like I just saw some stuff. I was looking for my nail clippers
And they're on my desk and I just remembered I used them when I was making the gunpla and I've been looking for them
I don't remember anything
Taser time
It tastes good taste good taste doesn't that really work well for this
It just gave up
Go on sis give me nothing with this
This kind of fun to do I feel like I'm soldering something there we go
Wait, I can't see the chat
Not sure how to best for this not necessarily looking for money answers just this isn't deeply the face of why they're not
I'll try my best
It's gonna be funny
Vod watchers are gonna see the part or I'm just like it was you had a terrible divorce
I just burned myself um
And then the bright guys gonna be like nah, and they'll be like so she was full of shit this entire
I was believing her up until that moment. It's gonna be funny as hell
Again, you can take what I say with a grain of salt. You don't believe
This is a sun and moon give up different energies in this practice. Yeah, this moon is kind of like
Your emotional side and the sun is kind of like your outward self
That's like kind of with your moon and your
Pain adds power
This is hard to be hard to shuffle with these stupid things in my hands
Can you not play over here mommy's working mommy's trying to connect with the spirits
I
Sorry
Had a vision I'm kidding
I'm just I was again centering myself and kind of just like mentally preparing myself for readings
They're like why does she just like stand sit there men is singly. I can't shuffle cool
That's not she me
It's a future that's so she I can't even I don't remember the that's what Raven theme song
That's so she be it's the future she can see. Oh, she doesn't predict the end of the world
No
The future is always changing if you're watching this right now, you're energetically
Aligned with me and the spirits and now you will
You were meant to see this this remember that that that vine I posted that fine the tick tock
I posted of that dude. That's me right now. I have I got my light skin eyes on I got my blue eyes
I'm staring at you. Hold on
I'm staring at you
How's the eagle stick doing today let's have some fun this beat is sick
I want to take a ride on your giggles stick. Don't think too much. Just bust a stick. Okay. I can tell
Candles mad at me
Watch me to focus
Time here is convoluted
Yeah
Okay, here's a general reading for everybody. What can we look forward to for the next let's say
Let's do
Should we do do you guys want to do like general reading for next month or do you want to do?
Love
Career
Finances
Do you're reading for Fia? Oh, no, she will she get better financially? She's great. She doesn't pay anything
Oh my god guys. Guess what by the way with Fia. Well, you guys are freaking it out
She was able to drink water by herself today, I didn't have to I didn't have the bottle here and
She's kicking her back legs and she can twist her front body and I'm so happy. She's getting better
By finances
Are you guys gay? Are you guys turning gay? All right, we'll do her reading
Are the harlots turning gay?
Months sounds good. All right, let's do let's do month
Three cards general month. Wait, can I delete?
It's a pinned message
Common Fia dub. Yep, she's great. She's she's doing amazing
She's doing awesome. I took pictures of this morning because she was being so cute. Hold on you focus
Connecting with the spiritual teams ancestors of everyone who is watching this video right now
We are wondering what will be it'll be the next month will be like what do we have to look forward to what do we have to watch out for
What should we know? What should we meditate on? What should we reflect on?
What do we need to know for the month of September for the beginning of the fall?
With the best intentions you would like answer I need to like move my arm under the camera wire because I'm gonna knock the camera over
I
Swear did temperance come out last time I did the reading on the Tamagotchi stream
What's my arcana
It did interesting, okay, it looks like we have a common theme
I might have to look back at that and see what I see what I pulled for that
This is very hard to shuffle with these freaking weird glove things on and these
All right
I
Didn't I see someone in the chat go please not death please not
Oh
It's funny
No, no, this is a good spread. This is a good good spread. This is a good spread
and
Then it would also pop those eight of ones. I think that means something, but I don't think it's relevant or you know
Death is not bad
I'll explain
So
We have a very good spread here for the month of September ladies and gentlemen. I'm pretty positive about this
So we have temperance
Beautiful card gorgeous gorgeous we have ten of pentacles
Gorgeous gorgeous
I'm trying to find out where the freaking camera is
Are these people just chilling that's you
The person who posts for those pictures in this chat what?
Then we have death upright also a very gorgeous card
It's funny this kind of reminds me of the the wheel of fortune
And then you have the faces of the moon very interesting
Death that's me
Yeah, because it's not your chair
I said this is a general reading for all of us death is not a bad thing guys
Everybody there's the death card has a bad rap. Okay. That's not it's not a bad thing
Is that the grim weeper
Okay, so this is for everybody I'm gonna get into the ones that people paid for after this
You're not dying
Yes, I don't like ten or nine of swords is
both
So temperance
Represents balance harmony healing patients self-control moderation purpose peace calm tranquility and serenity
Ten of pentacles represents dynasty leaving a legacy inheritance wealth financial security long-term success
roots family ancestry privilege affluence
Death represents symbolic death and rebirth big changes time to move on transformation
Transition endings letting go release starting anew
My candle getting real happy
She bright um
My chest is itchy
So
Again, so temperance is a common is a continuous theme that was in my last reading that I did in my tomagotchi stream
And I think this is just reminding us to stay on the path of just like balancing our emotions
Um, you know just
Pouring so cups usually represent emotions
So you can see this person is pouring into another cup. She is also very enlightened. She's an angel
Um, I feel like this is your spiritual team reminding you to kind of like
Offload your burdens on to others like you might feel like your burdens on but like I think you need to vent a little bit you can
Kind of building stuff up and that can lead to an explosion and that's not there's there's no harmony in that
So and also you need to be able to heal. So if you'd be able to like talk to somebody
Kind of attain that emotional balance kind of like not keep everything. You're so weighed down
So it's time to open up
You also, you know continue to practice self-control a month of September
You just be like
The overarching theme we're gonna be calm. We're gonna be awesome. We're gonna be serene. We're gonna be chilling
we're gonna be
Yeah, just attaining that sense of balance just
You know, I'm surprised the justice card didn't stand up with the scales and just be like, yeah
I'm gonna vent to my mirror but honestly
Like that's not a bad like if you have no one to vent to like kind of just do some emotional
Um, so like what is
Really good you can you know, I probably did this in like school because I remember doing this in school when I was younger
You know, how you would like write a bunch of words like crazy and you would just like I think they like used it for like
Writing prompts and you would just like put a bunch of ideas down that was like your your brainstorm or whatever the fuck they called it in school
So writing your thoughts down
But then like tear them up and let them go or like set them on fire because everybody loves flames. Am I right?
um
I think you should kind of
And I think that has to do with the death card too because this is letting go moving on that's like I'll get to that though
so I feel like
You need to do some emotional
like
Removing of weight from yourself like you've been carrying a lot
Um, and I think that's good that we do that self-love jar. I think that's applicable here
Yeah fire is cool. Um
Yeah, shout out a tree shout into the go touch grass and I don't mean like touch grass like
like internet touch grass like there's um
Literally something you could do could just like go barefoot outside if the weather is good and just kind of sit with yourself
And kind of let yourself feel feel the earth
Feel the dirt between your toes feel the grass
Feel the little wetness in your pants
Because you're accidentally sat on a wet spot or do you pee yourself? Whatever help you know floats your boat
um
Candles twitching um
Just connect with nature, but like let yourself feel
I think like I had a good cry
Like yesterday for no reason because I'm like I feel like I had been bottling stuff up
Because sometimes you just need to cry like I'm like I don't even know I'm crying but like sometimes you just need to
Just cry bro. I'm just like
Be a real man and cry real man cry. That's all I'm gonna say
What if you don't know how to cry, I don't know look at like dead puppies or something. Okay, you know through that
Don't do that
um
What the heck I was like
What is that it's a bug
It's not a bug ladies and gentlemen. It is not a bug just a just a piece of dirt
um
Yeah, don't bottle stuff up or you're gonna explode
All right, 10 of pentacles
Uh, so wealth financial security success. I feel like if you have any project, whoa
What's going on with you candle?
You going crazy over there. So I guess this means paying attention
um
If you have
Any sort of projects that you've been
Working on or feel like I feel like those will kind of pan out for you
um
This also has to do with like dynasty and family connect with your family
uh
And this doesn't have to be like your blood related family like people who work again
I get with the pouring out of emotions. I feel like you just need to hang out with people
Go and hang out with people the month of september
Uh, I don't know if you guys like if you're american
September apple picking go apple picking with your family
Go do false stuff with your go have a pumpkin spice latte
With someone with a close friend that you consider
I don't know like a sibling
I imagine she'd be graduating the waterworks with flow. Um
Go uh
Yeah, connect with your family connect with your history because this is dynasty
I feel like you might like find some cool stuff about yourself
If you like ask a family member or like do some research
In like a library or like, I don't know where you can do research on your family
I don't know do some like self-discovery of like history and stuff
I feel like like that'll be important for some of like if someone who's been interested in about their past
Uh, I think that applies to you
um
But yes, I think just spending time with family
Like spend time with your little sister emmy, you know
spend time with your little sister
With your little sister. I see spend time with me your big sister spend time with your mom Missouri spend time with your
your
I was like your cousin shrani your cousin mercy
Go if your english go biscuit picking. Oh my god
Aunt straw me your cool aunt straw me
Um, but yeah like to spend time. I think like kind of connecting with people will be essential
um
The month of september go to your roots
I think you might gain some knowledge from like I feel like you should connect with older ones
Because there's many different generations in this picture. There's like young
teenager
Adult and like an older gentleman in here
I feel like maybe kind of connecting with people of all ages in your family or like someone older that might have some wisdom
might be super prevalent the month of september for some of you
um
Also says privilege check your privilege. No, I'm kidding. Um
But yeah, so somebody might have some advice for you or like just tell you something that you really needed to hear
You know like someone just it just hits just right
I think that's necessary. Um, I don't but it says wealth and financial security
So maybe you'll make some better financial decisions, but that means like don't be impulsive and stuff, you know
um, but yeah
Say psych
Strani's definitely the why not
What if we don't want to wake me up wake up till september ends? I'm so sorry
Call your grandma. She misses you. I feel like this is telling me to call my grandma
I'm gonna call my grandma then like a month
And if I don't want to talk to friends and family
Okay, then don't you don't have to listen to what I'm telling you
I know I need to talk to my grandparents
I would they're probably like, we're the hailey man
And I've been invited to a lot of family stuff that I've been putting off. So maybe I need to I need to work on that
Okay, so our emotion getting emotionally well connecting the family the dying, correct
You are right. No, I'm kidding. Um, so death
I felt it
You've all felt it. There is a major change coming the month of september
I have felt so weird the month of august. I have felt off. I have felt something is wrong
I didn't know if it was because mercury was in retrograde. It's on the other planetary stupid stuff was going on
But something isn't right
That's going to change
In september you want to know why?
Because death. Oh my candles don't come crazy death represents the end of a cycle
It doesn't mean someone's dying it can but this is not what that reading is for
um
It means there's going to be a change big change. It's going to be a transition
remember after death
Death begets life life begets death
all right
The world's not ending guys calm down
I will connect with my ancient greek philosopher ancestors. Oh go for it, bro
But she be what if I don't want to not slaughter my enemies in the name of aries. That's too bad
That's too bad. You have to
It's your birthright
um
You just go chibi
Yeah, september is pretty close. It's literally
How many days away?
How is there 30 30?
I can't do math. I'm blood
um
But but yeah
So
It's symbolic death and rebirth you're going to be reborn
Also this again
I said that this reminds me of the wheel of fortune and the what the wheel of fortune is is the wheel always turns stuff always changes
You're going through life. You're going through transitions
You're going through a cycle and then you also have the moon phases here around but you can also see this light
It's like enlightenment. I always see these little rays of light are like enlightenment
You're going to learn some things about yourself the month of september. You didn't anticipate some of you
Um, you're going to be starting something new
But in order for these things in order for the positive things that I mentioned to happen like
Connecting with family properly monetary success attending balance and you know emotional maybe some emotional stability
You have to let things go
Some of you got oh candle going crazy
That is the theme right there. You have to let stuff go
Are you holding on to something that does no longer serve you?
Why are you holding on to that one kid that stole 20 bucks from you?
Don't do it. Let it go
Let it go
Forget about it
So released runges are not serving you
If you have some sort of hatred or dislike
But you don't even like interact with someone or like there's a subject that's bothering you
Let it go
Who cares?
Because I want it back
I guess this user is so insecure compared to julius. He gave august another day
I know he was like actually
Hello
Um, but yeah, just like
You know
Chill out allow stuff to happen allow stuff to change just embrace
this death of the month of law like a whole new
I don't know
One new just like if you're starting college in the fall and it's gonna be a new chapter. There's gonna be new chapters
And it's interesting and it's so appropriate too because when you think of fall you think of
in a way
death
That it's getting colder
plants start dying
Leaves fall everything is bare
But you know after fall after winter
Life comes back there's spring so you know you will be okay
You know, you'll be fine
Hello, hi, hi people. Hello go come in. Um, but yeah, so in short
If you're just getting here, I just did a general reading for everyone
We pulled temperance ten of pentacles of death by the way, this is important when you see major arcana cards
Which are these ones not the numbered cards, you know, it's important. Um, so
Temperance attain emotional balance
Keep up that self-control do some
um, kind of like
emotional
Practices where you need to like kind of it's funny because it's probably letting things go with the death and then this and like writing stuff
Up and like throwing it away. So like
I'm trying I can't think of the word
My throat chakra is blocked
Usually when my throat chakra blocked, I mean, I feel like some people don't speak up for themselves as well
So I feel like somebody's to speak up for themselves if they keep getting like pushed down
Um
Yeah
Okay, you're not if you feel like you don't have any self-worth because you can't speak up then do something about that
um
Treats me getting naked. I love I love fall falls. Maybe we're two
Um, ten of pentacles connect with your family that might give you good advice on older ones
So, uh, I feel like someone's someone is going to tell you something you need to hear
I don't have to be family if family doesn't have to be blood by the way
So people who are just close to you try to connect with family. I know some of you are meets
I need to connect with my family. I haven't talked to my family. I was supposed to go to the movies with my dad again
And I totally forgot I needed to be like, hey
Sir, I don't know why I'm texting my phone this way like I'm typing on a computer. But yeah
Um, but yeah
So that and then death september will be a new cycle for everyone. It's be a new
Um beginning we're transitioning into kind of a new
You know, I might pull another card because I don't know what
Cycle we are transitioning into so actually let me pull one more card for the general
What sort of transition can we expect the month of september?
What should we be looking out for? Oh the cards are
When my cards just like jumps into the flames and catches fire
Dude who is like holding on to something that is so interesting
Ada cups
Okay, so in the fall in september the new cycle will be moving on so we will be letting go of things. Um
Moving on letting go searching for truth
Maybe we'll get a sort of truth. Maybe there's been something we've been searching for for a long time
We never got any answers to so maybe we'll get some answers
Leaving maybe you need to leave a toxic situation
Um walking away into the unknown
Transition might be you don't know what's going to happen next but you need to get out of there, you know
Um
Remember men crying is bad. Shut up. No not true. I love men that can cry
This is the connection the family reading this is relevant. This is what yeah
Yeah, he doesn't have to be with
That's why I'm saying like family doesn't have to be blood because I know
Like I have people in my family that I just don't talk to you because they suck
Clip it out. I know
Um
There's also abandonment
I remember I pulled this card for somebody last um last time I did readings
Some of you might have to abandon things that just don't
Benefit you anymore and just move on from them or maybe you felt abandoned personally
And you need to move on from it. Like I know like I have like abandonment issues up the wazoo. So
I
Crying we're just like sorry chat. They're just gonna start puking everywhere
Everyone start crying crying everyone everyone cry
I'm gonna make harem and the crest of the pin pals
Or gay reeflings or vomitors harem or cry babies
Bleeding hearts and snippets and snowberries. I don't know what's going on with y'all but y'all can figure yourselves out
I threw up
Not the reeflings the reeflings are puking
I know I have like three crying. I'm also have another crying one on the I think I have two crying ones on the way
You guys are gonna be the cry babies
All right, but yeah, I hope that
resonated if not
Totally understandable. You do not have to believe a word. I say take it with a grain of salt
Don't use it for financial advice. Don't use it to predict if you're pregnant or not
Don't sue me. Thank you
It is just for entertainment purposes
Don't sue me
All right, now I'm gonna get into what time is it? Oh my god, it's already almost nine
What it took me an hour to do a read. Okay. Well, it's fine
Um, don't worry about it. You will hear the cat food dispenser go off. I wanted to do this before then but it's okay
Why are you only contacting you? Okay
Flower head
Can I get a reading out I just wrote myself
well
Boomi, why are you laughing at me? Did you hear that you went?
Um, can I get a reading for my future or any weird spot where I'm doing everything
Can I find a good job and better my future with everyone telling me I'm doing fine?
Yeah, I still feel like I'm not doing enough. Sorry. That's too broad. I feel like you just want a purpose
And honestly, I get that like I turn to a lot of what I do because I needed a perfect like before I was a beach like
Literally before I was a vtuber
I was struggling to find purpose because I was at my job. I had been there for almost six years and I'm like, what am I doing?
What am I doing with my life? Like I don't
Know what to do
You know, like I just needed a purpose
And so I kind of like that's when people like, you know, like turn into god turn to god and stuff
And you don't blame them because sometimes you need a little bit of faith to find your purpose
Um, and this was that for me. So I totally get that
I'm sorry that you're that you're going through that
What's the trap
I think she beat that was all bullshit, but it was inspiring bullshit. So I feel good. No problem, bro. No problem
Anytime I will always be bullshit at you
Please do not invest your life savings in NFTs
I can relate a bit. I already know the dream stuff
I want but stuff's in the way so professional fits in between. Yeah, because like this is a dream of mine
But I never thought it would ever be attainable, but I guess I just
I guess I'm a product
Like I'm I'm
Proof that it's real like your dreams can come true
But only if you work hard at them because I remember
when I was
Trying to figure myself out and I was just like I want to be a vtuber
I went to a psychic and she was just like well, it just doesn't happen overnight. Are you gonna like start and I'm like
true
And so I started and I started initially with this like
Kind of seeing it as a job rather than a hobby
And I was like I just want to be agency and I just want to do this this and that
And I knew I wasn't doing it for the right reasons
And went back and she's just like you're not doing it for the right reasons. I'm like, how do you fucking know?
How do you know what I meant because she's just like it was funny the second goes
um
you were
You're into like
You're into anime right and like mind you. I don't have anything. I don't have anything on my person
I don't look like a weeb. I don't
And I'm not like
And she's just like you like internet stuff like you want to be a content creator and has to do with anime and I'm like
How did you fucking know that bitch? How did you know?
And she's like don't worry. It'll work out for you, but you got to do stuff about it. I'm like facts. All right, bet
let's do it
um
Is she a psychic or uncle?
I wrote holy crap the insight she got a whiff of the weave. I don't know
And I was like look I like looked at myself in the mirror and I'm like do I look like a weeb
Do I do I just give off weed but but this woman was like 60 years old mind you
I don't
I don't I don't know
You smell the weird on you
But I don't look like a weeb if you saw me you'd be like she looks pretty normal
Raina, can you stop hissing at boomi?
Um but anyways my story and but um then
uh
I remember doing my own
Reading for myself and essentially the reading said give us something to bless like show us that you want it
and so I streamed
constantly four times five times a week
um
While working a full-time job
for
of almost six months
And I worked really hard. I did a lot of research. I did a lot of like
growing
Learning about the community a bunch of stuff and then I gave them something to bless and then they
Got me what I wanted which was literally
I didn't become a vtuber to like
get into v alert, but um
I always knew like when
scrawny was conceptualizing and stuff back when she was you know leaf or whatever
Like I always loved it and then when I became a vtuber like three months after I was in D. I'm like
It's happening. I want I have to be a part of this. I want to be a part of this
I like I need to be like I know I'm meant to be a part of this and I got in
And I'm here
Chibi I'm sorry to say but normal people watch anime now. No not the gnomies
Madame you are wearing mesh gloves and spikes. You're one eyepatch
You
I was very chuney when I was younger
Um, all right, anyways, I know
What does flower head need to do to find their purpose this is about to go out
What do they need to do connecting with flower head spiritual team what can motivate them what can help them
Can I pull this card for you before I don't remember
What do they need to know what do they need to hear what do they need to be told
Interesting interesting interesting
Interesting, okay. I need more cards. I need more can I get a clarification card for the two of pentacles, please?
Thank you very much
That's too much clarification. I need a little bit only like one card. Oh, perfect
Actually
Huh, huh
I'm sensing a block which I totally get because what you said there's a block there's like something
I don't really know how to what to put my finger on it
But I I get your what you're feeling right now that you don't know what you're supposed to do because I also have this feeling of like
kind of like hopelessness and restlessness and like
Just a general kind of like I have a sense of confusion
I have confusion
That one lady who was talking about
Why is it our Kansas?
Why is it's not our Kansas? Why is it Arkansas?
My nails look funny. Oh, thank you. Don't worry. I'll take a better picture
Take a better picture
um
The card flip is what spirituals you can fucking get
All right, so you have queen of cups in reverse
She fallen you have knight of wands upright
I can't remember if I pulled a knight for you last time. I think I did
And you have two of pentacles and then you have I'll show you two pentacles
Yep
And then you have justice in reverse and you also have the hanged man in reverse
Very interesting. We have two major arcana cards
very very interesting
So this is for um
Flower head. So this is you right now. I already know the queen of cups is you right now
But I'm also going to tell you what you need to be reminded of what makes you special
Wait, what?
Let's make this a bit simpler as I'm not sure I can articulate the other question properly without going into more detail than I want
How about we just do where should my folks be for the next moment? Okay. Hey, okay. I understand
Okay, I kind of see that better
No, don't worry. Don't worry special. I saw your I saw your initial thing. You didn't have to you didn't have to donate again
Reversed hang man, that's good or is it?
Well, you learned it a little bit
um
So this is you right now flower head
Do not take this personally
Also, wait, wait, I always have to ask when I'm doing a personal reading
Do you want me to be blunt or you don't do you want me to sugarcoat stuff by the way?
There are no bad cards in my opinion
Do
Flower head died flower head where are did you fall asleep? Oh cat food going off
They haven't talked in a while they must be dead
You
Food dispenser mind below fed
Rest in peace flower whole flower head everyone rest in peace flower head blunt. Oh, okay. There you are
I've even lurking. I'm sorry wake up
Okay, he's like blunt
You're insecure. Don't know what for
Something something when you walk through the no seriously assistant security you're insecure as fuck. What's wrong with you? Um, you're overly sensitive
You're needy
You're fragile
You have some sort of codependence
You have victim mentality right now. You've been giving away too much of yourself
Yeah, that's to you right now
Uh
But you need a reminder
You need a reminder
Of what you can be
And I will tell you
Because you have great qualities
And I don't want I'm not saying this to hurt you. I'm just making I'm saying stuff so that you're self
aware, okay
Why do you who made you feel insecure? Why do you not feel like you're good enough? Why are you so sensitive if someone critiques you?
Was does somebody make a comment and that kind of rocked your shit?
You know
I and then it says needy. So again, you're you're looking to me for reassurance. You're looking to an anime girl on the internet
Nothing wrong with that
So you're a little fragile right now. You're experiencing some codependence issues
You're relying on stuff that you shouldn't be relying on
To work to focus that worked out your feelings, you know
And that's why you've been feeling aimless is because you're holding yourself black black
You're holding yourself back
Uh you
Hold on. He's me and if this applies to you then you can like, you know, you can absorb it as well
Shut up everybody shut up. Um
How's my hand thought you
The reason why you feel like you're not
Doing good enough or whatever. It's because you just
You're also comparing yourself to other people, you know, like I was chat stops. Listen
Um
You are enough you are doing enough
I don't know why you can't see this because let me let me gas you up a little bit flower head
Let me gas you up. You know what you are. You know what the qualities you do have that your spiritual team your ancestors your peoples
Your your your dead pet from a couple years ago wants you to know
You're courageous
You're energetic when you want to be
You can be extremely charming
And charismatic you're passionate
When you have the motivation when something super interests you
You feel adventurous sometimes
And it doesn't have to be like, oh i'm gonna go climb a mountain. It could be like i'm trying this new food
You feel free spirited you're a hero you look out for the little guy
You look out for the little guy
You have a drive
You're missing that drive though
You know why you're missing that drive because you're insecure right now. You need to stop you need to stop
I don't know a song popped into my head. What was the song? I got it. Then I lost it
The song having to do with driving. I don't know why
I can't remember what it was
There's a lot of dead animals in the stream
You would be correct
I need someone to like ID that skull for me. Um
But yeah, don't forget those amazing qualities you have you're pushing them down because of your insecurity
I want you to
Think about the these good things I've told you
I want you to think about your past successes
and what you came from
Because you you've been through some shit, bro
You've been through some shit
And you forget about it. Sometimes you forget where you came from, bro
I don't know why i'm acting ganks all of a sudden, but I am
That's a bird
What's that one like ticked uh ticked talk. That's just like
um
Oh my god, it's like you think it's a bird like
That's like when I heard ticked talks I forget the context though. Um, but yeah
All right, I was I the sense of confusion I get because I
These two cars are very interesting to me with the two of pentacles. So two of pentacles
You got this person balancing monies and this is funny because you're talking about your career and stuff
Um, so this is choices multitasking decisions weighing up options multiple priorities
So usually when I pull like a choice or a two card
I usually pull two cards after for verification and kind of just or clarification rather just to see okay
What are the two choices? What's going on here? Um
But it seems like you're you're you can be a man of many hats you juggle a lot of stuff
um
You try to balance a lot, but you don't usually over encumber yourself
But you have to be careful not to get caught up in stuff and take up
Too much like you don't want to be so stuck weighing your options
Like having this like am I good enough or am I am I going anywhere in my life like you've been having?
um
You have to like make a choice like you've been delaying something you just have to
Fucking pick something, you know, uh, I know you've just got a job or whatever
I feel like there's something in the job or like
That you need to do like you need to make a choice on
Or like someone's like puts it like giving you a choice like you have to do this or that and you're like
What the fuck do I do because like am I good enough to do this task or like do I do this other task?
It's what I know or like it's easier for me. Blah blah blah blah. Um, that's him the bird is dead
um, so you have the justice reverse
in the hate man in reverse so something
So dishonesty unfairness bigotry lawsuits legal issues dishonest why is dishonesty twice? I don't understand
uh lack of accountability
retribution
Look at this this card is actually pretty gorgeous. I never really looked at it. She has like a flame in her chest
Well, I would like a souls like game based on tarot cards. Holy shit
That'd be so cool. Imagine fighting a lady
who's like made of scales
Sorry, I'm getting off topic
dishonesty squared. Okay, and then you have
Hanged man in reverse
Here I'll show what it looks like when it's upright, but when it's reverse it's like that
um delays resistance and decisions standstill apathy selfishness victim mentality again
You have two victim mentalities
Disinterest stagnation avoiding sacrifice
So what I like about the hangman the hangman is all about like kind of going out on a limb and um attaining a new perspective
That's why I like the level I like about that card, but you have been very close minded
So you've had these choices you've not been opened to new ideas because you're stuck in your own head
You're stuck in your own world. We need that to stop
Um because you're experiencing again this victim mentality
You're gonna be okay
dishonesty
um
I don't know if that like
means something to you maybe something because like I see like
Again dishonesty is twice
I don't know if somebody's lying to you if you've been
thinking that someone's lying. Uh, it's also bigotry. Um
Are you a bigot? That's terrible
my camera's
All right
Um, Haiti styled game of tarot cards instead of greek. That's literally call to the lamp and I'm finding a visik though
um
What is in my fucking eye?
Something's in my eye
Ow what the hell
Something's in your eye you're not seeing the full picture
Maybe I don't know. Um
Is it your eyeball? Oh, is it your eyeball? Oh, is it your eyeball?
Um
I'll be honest with you. I'll be real with you
You have two paths laid in front of you. There is a lesser of two evils, but it's going to be bumpy so I
You're I feel like you'll get what you like
You're still gonna be stuck in this headspace until you get over those things
And because you're stuck in these headspace it can go one way with the inverse justice or another way
uh with the hanged man, so um everything kind of being at a stand
I feel like I need another card. I need some sort of
Like
What can be the choice is like what does he have to look forward after this?
Like is there a positive outcome or is he so stuck in his head?
He needs to go through that does he need to go through this? This is a necessary
Um part of his life that he needs to go through does he need to get over himself before he can find his purpose? Oh my
I
You guys didn't see it but the card landed in the trash can
The card landed in my trash can
Oh
Uh someone needs to be taken out to the trash
Perfect this is what I wanted to see ace of wands
Ace of wands it was like sideways so it wasn't upright or
Reversed it was literally in the trash like this
And with that I usually will read both sides
If you
You have to
If someone's being dishonest get rid of them because you're only going down go down the path of a continuous creative block
Someone's going to hurt and ruin you. I don't know who it is get them out of your life
Um, someone's giving you bad advice. I don't know who it is. They're being just honest
They're telling you stuff that you like you need to hear things and they're not telling you
You
Lawsuits legal. No, I have no idea. There's nothing to do with that. However, this is this is actually good. This is the this is the portion
If you are okay with a little bit of delay
A little bit of indecisiveness if you kind of move forward, but you don't let this person influence you
I feel like it's a female presence
because the justice card is female
Then
You have the possibility of ace of wands ace again ace one new beginning a new start
New project inspiration ignited passion new opportunities growth potential energy creative spark new initiative
Enthusiasm, that's what you wanted. That's what you wanted. I don't know who this fucking person is who's dishonest
Fucking big it is get them out of your life get them leave them kick them out. Boom. They're not helping you
They're not serving you. I don't know if that's relevant
Who knows
It's it's me as you gotta get rid of me. I'm so just enemy
Just just knock me out
um
because if you continue to work with this person or
For rejection false start more delays more blocks lack of direction and passion
Distractions lack of energy hesitancy creative blocks. You've been wondering what the heck you're doing with your life
This person has not been helpful to you
There's somebody that's not telling you how it is
I'm sub right now
But yeah, I I don't know flower head if that was relevant to you at all
It's gonna be a long journey. It's gonna be a long road. You will get through it. You will have that passion back
But you need to work
On your insecurity you need to work on this person or like remove this person from your life that might be being dishonest
I don't know why I couldn't just speak then I just literally like lost my tongue
Uh, I don't know if you're scared to talk to that person, but early you can just like quietly get rid of them
Um, and then you know, you'll have some delays
You will find that creative project that new start you've been looking for it'll take
Time just keep working at it work on yourself
You could you know, you always get that thing like you gotta love yourself before you love other people
You gotta work on yourself before you can work on a new project in your case. That's it tdlr
tldr
too
Long didn't read tldr. Yeah
All right, who next these readings are gonna go a lot longer than I thought they would
Two didn't long read tdlr tdl sounds better
Rightful chaos capricorn. How will a back half of my year go like the next few months rightful chaos or no problem
Did that resonate like it was I full of shit? You can tell the people if I was full of shit
Um
Rightful are you alive rightful? Hello righteous rightful rightful right hello? Hello? Hello?
Hello
Sir
All right full chaos I keep reading your name is righteous chaos
Next couple months. Oh, okay. Got you. Got you. Okay, because I didn't like do you mean like six months?
Or do you mean like the little end of the year? All right, cool
Hi, if you're new here, I'm sheebie. I am raising some cards for everybody today
My butt hurts
She begins the worst Tarto card readings ass to leave the witches association
The chaos is rightful righteous rightful
righteous
Whoa actually like just like ripped off the thing on my I think I have this like on my chest for the whole bit
All right
I
I'm not I've already queued up the people who are doing readings. I probably should have put it on the screen, but I'm too lazy
um
So I already took six people so I will I've already done one I have five more to go
So this will be a bit
Yeah, I need I need a massage
I'm hungry. What should I eat?
I need to go grocery shopping guys. I didn't do that today
You like the character. Thank you
I definitely always look like this 24 seven
I
Like that or like like the like the it's called a bridge. I can't do a bridge. These cards are too stiff
Just joined how does this work you listen to me? Yeah, that's how this works
I've already hold on let me just
Let me just
Oh
You are welcome to role play. No, that's not the case. Um, we're not role playing
I
Fuck should I put this
I can't read that
I
That work stick it on my face. Wait, hold on
Because you guys are all gonna look at my booba first
You all come in and you stare at my boobs
Oh, who me? What are you doing?
Sir, wait a second
I left the light on in my room and I realized it's off
Hold on a moment
I love my bedroom
Stop it get some help
Spirit's inky no, they're not inky
They're playing with me possibly I should probably
Stop
Stupid freaking rug. It's like it's the same rug I ordered before. Why is this one trash?
I
I guess trash because of and shit to fake it what?
Who how do I get like left behind in my own stream like I am
In 30 minutes behind I don't know how that works
How does that work when I've been watching my own stream because I had the chat up that doesn't
Make it make sense
Or built different
Accidentally just on did my shirt. It's fine
Oh
I think I know why would I type something like I have a rose up right now
Because then that goes to the very beginning of my stream
I press the toggle. That's why
Get out of full screen
It's the ADHD
Alakazam turn of the ash, okay
Who's next? Oh, yeah, I forgot
All right, I'm gonna do this one more time
Um
I don't understand
Why my neighbor just does not give a shit
about when her kids run
Screaming down the hallway when it's nine at night. I don't I do have any
Common
Like I don't understand
Like stop how like I just piss like every fucking night when they come home
They are but why did they come on my nine? I don't fucking sorry. I'm angry
I'm just so irritated because it always fucking happens
I
Yeah, they're so loud
They're so loud
Oh that candle's going out
Say goodbye haters
We're still holding on
Just kidding
I got so much wax on this
Exxon wax off
Pop the wax off
Sorry connecting with right again, I'm just grounding myself before I go to the next one connecting myself with right
Spiritual team sorry, but we did something
Pop you're distracting me do you need a little bit of laughter in your life chaos?
It's a funny sentence
The wheel be turning
The wheel be turning did I pull us three last time? I don't know
And I remember I'm seeing cards I pulled last time
Whoa
This is pretty good so far very positive into your year
At least so far I've still one more card to pull I can go for a laugh. Just look in the mirror now
I'm sorry. I love you. I didn't mean it. I was just trying to make you laugh. I swear. Don't get mad at me
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. It just happened to just come down. Please don't cry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry
I'm sorry
This one's running away you get a bonus card
You're gonna came
You
All right
Pretty generally you got a lot of a lot of a lot of you got two pentacles cards. You got wheel fortune
page of pentacles wheel fortune queen of pentacles
page of
I feel like you're going through a
like
Growing you're gonna be growing at the end of the year. I feel like you're growing
Like you're gonna be learning new skills just by like the page going to the queen
But then you're gonna be going, you know learning another skill and it's a page of wands and then eventually you get to like the queen of wands
Um, you're a woman now by the way, and I'm kidding. That's not how this works
um
The growth of chaos
so
page of pentacles
manifestation
Grounded ambitious
offering a gift
goal-oriented financial opportunity planner consistent loyal faithful messenger
I feel like the page of pentacles is a little bit childish, but I feel like in this case
You've been trying to be very like adult money-minded and mindful of like spending stuff
And I think that's paying off for you. I feel like you've been kind of trying to be a little bit careful
um
And I think this is kind of just validation to continue to be grounded
Um continue to chase that bag sis
Uh because it will pan out for you, you know
Congrats on all
Um chibi who's chibi?
Um
I feel like you should spread that
Well, this could be a wealth of like knowledge, you know, I hear in my garage
Knowledge sorry, um or this could be monetary
But I feel like you should share this with other people because this is offering a gift. I feel like
you might gain
Some happiness from sharing this with somebody else, you know, I I love giving gifts to people
I don't know why gift giving to others is my love language
um is one of them
But it's funny because then like I don't I'm not a huge like gift receiver because I feel like I'm not good enough
So I feel like you'll feel good if you're like kind of spread that love
Yeah, keep keep an eye on that money. Um
And you know your manifestations have been paying off and like I know like like me and Icy throw or in the word like
I'm manifesting that a lot, but like
Manifestation it's like it's literally a mindset when you really break it down
It's a sigma male alpha male mindset where you're just like
I'm fucking doing this. This is gonna happen for me
Yeah, and like continue to do that if you're like, you know what I've been saving for this
I've been doing that. I want this. This is mine. Keep that up. You'll get it. You'll get what you want
You'll get what you need
Because your team really wants you to have it. They're willing to help you provide help provide for you
and again wheel of fortune
The wheel turns
And it's upright for you right now
Good luck fate life cycles destiny a turning point
The universe is in control changes cycle karma unexpected events
I feel like you'll have some positive unexpected events towards the end of the year
um like something like
Generally good will happen to you that you weren't anticipating and you'll be like holy shit
like I didn't expect to be able to
um
Get this opportunity or talk to this person or like you'll just have something that you've been wanting that'll like
Kind of just show up and you're like whoa sick like it'll be just really nice, you know
um
And this is a big I feel like this year like the like towards the end of the year
Like I'm saying like towards the end of the year like towards the new year. Um
The new year will be a very interesting cycle for you
You'll be experiencing new things, but it's it's part of life. It's your fate. It's your destiny
Um, you're gonna be going through some stuff that it's necessary for you to experience and you continue to grow as a person
So you can turn into this queen of pentacles and continue get your money up son. Um
Nurturing practical generous welcoming sensible luxurious caring homebody good business sense working working parent
You're a dad. Congratulations. Uh, our child is due very soon for kidding. Um
I feel like once you cultivate
The skills that you want and get the stuff that you want to manifest the stuff that you want
You will become this this queen of pentacles
Um, I feel like you already have a lot of these
Traits by the way
Um, I feel like if you continue to share your wealth with other people and continue to be generous and caring
That karma and the wheel of fortune is going to come back to you like you're doing good deeds
Of course, you're gonna receive good deeds back to you. You know
um, so
I'm so ready for the I know I'm I'm I'm so ready for for fall
I'm ready. I like I like cozy giant clothes. Uh, you'll be seeing I have to go
I have to go I haven't gone clothes shopping in like four years
I'm wearing the same clothes for years
Sad um anyways
um
But yeah, and it'll continue to keep the good business sense sticks out to me continue to be mindful just because you're gonna be
Successful doesn't mean you should squander the opportunities and the success you have continue to have that good business sense and be sensible
Um page of wants that I think after you do that
When you get that success in that area that you want you'll be like, okay time to start something new
And the other thing that's been in the back of your mind that you didn't think you'd be able to get to because you had to
Just do this other thing first. You'll be able to start so that we'll have to do with adventure
I don't know. I feel like something you have want to like go on a trip
There's a trip you want to go on something you want to see
um
cheerfulness energetic fearlessness discovery young spirit limitless potential
Act over extrovert first ideas. I feel like you'll be able to go on some sort of adventure
trip that you've been wanting to do to discover more about yourself
um
Yeah, I ask this is very positive
I feel like you just really need to keep on the path that you're on and like the next
Ladder half of the year and into the new year is going to be very
productive for you. So keep keep keep keep at it, bro
Keep at it. I hope that hope that feels good and resonates
This ring is hurting me. I don't know if you guys see like I have this like ring that's like a little claw
He is digging into my fingy
Oh, okay, we didn't believe before I do now that's pretty close to me. Oh, yeah, cool nifty
Good for you. I'm numb. I'm numb. I'm glad that that resonated with you. I'm happy
Yeah, feel free to tell me if I'm full of shit guys like for real for real
Oh
My finger
My little my little my little pinky
You have to mark
Not really
Can't really
It's crunching. All right
Rap battle voice who's next
Sedaterious, how can I better manage jealous feelings? Oh
X2 doki
Oh my god, doki bird. No way
Oh
That's shiver
Weird
Gotta gotta chill in the air
Is that bad? No, it's not bad. I just got a shiver. That was not nothing to do with your reading. I'm sorry
Sometimes stuff does pertain to readings like external factors, but this is this is that was not I know that was not
That was just me because I got a shiver
Connect me with X2 doki spiritual team ancestors the guys that look over
How can they manage jealous feelings? What can they work on? What can they be doing to improve upon receiving these feelings?
Get over yourself. No, I'm sorry. I don't know why that popped out of me. Wow
Jesus Christ
What is going on here?
That don't make no sense. Please tell me I need more cards. I wanted three
Oh
Give me four. All right, then. I'll take it
Holy shit. No kidding
Oh
You're dying in seven days. I'm kidding
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. Um, so you got six of cups eight swords nine of swords nine of cups
Doki
The W what the fuck is going on, babe? Oh, baby girl
Sorry neighbors
It's weird seeing shadows of feet under my door
Do you perhaps live in the castle me or or doki?
I
Don't know why something keeps telling me get over yourself
I don't know why I keep thumping into my head. Oh
I'm so sorry. I don't know why
Oh, that's like that's I don't know something somebody's screaming. There's a spirit screaming. Yeah
Yeah
All right, you got six of cups, which is nostalgia
Childhood or the past memories familiarity gifts innocence or reunion joy healing comfort sentimentality and pleasure
I feel like this is someone that you either dated previously
Or they give you like a childhood friend that you grew up with and you're kind of jealous about how they're growing
um
Or stop screaming. Um
You're kind of jealous of been what's been going on in their life and what they've been attaining
And you kind of looking at yourself and you're like, what's wrong with me? Why don't I have this? I deserve some of this like
You know
um
I know welcome back. There's no flop jack. I'm even about a Sapphire. Oh man. That was a great show. Um
Yeah, I like our so it's either
um
No, I'm not I'm not gonna say that. Um
Could you're also like kind of like lingering on the past a lot?
like
Oh, but like when I like I I can't talk
Sorry, give me a second
You're just jealous of everybody around you that you grew up with or something. I don't even like
You're just looking at other people
Oh, I like or again or like I said, or it's like an x
Like a childhood friend or like someone that you dated and you're just kind of like frustrated seeing where they're at
And you're kind of like what about me and then your spiritual teams talk to say
I don't know why I'm talking like a like a tomboy
But your spiritual teams like come on you like stop lingering on it get over yourself like stop
Because you got you got this thing got ace of swords staring you in the face
You got a breakthrough. You got truth new insights new ideas vision focus mental clarity and success
But this jealousy keeps preventing you from moving forward. So you're stuck in the nine of swords, which is anxiety
depression
sleepless nights because you're so fucking jealous winding why everybody's doing this and you're not and you need stop to compare yourself to people
because
um
I really people like
Adults will look at people their own age and see their successes and wonder why they're not in the same spot
But they forget that everybody has a different journey spiritual and physical and you need to like stop
Um overthinking fear nightmares paranoia negativity isolation despair stop it
stop
Bow bow stop it
Bow bow bow bow bow
Um tarot cards are a divination tool if you're new hello
Um
The jealousy is holding you back
And I know it's like you're wondering how to manage your jealousy and that's what it literally is this is like stop
Worrying about other people like you're preventing yourself because you're worrying about other people and you're caught up about where you should be
When you're not just like happy with what you've accomplished and
You're comparing yourself to other people or you're comparing yourself to this guy that that dude
That that dude that that girl has been seeing that you've been pissed about
And you're like whatever bro, she wasn't for you you spoke to teams like she wasn't for you bro get over it
And again, if like one part like this might not
Like if you're this isn't your reading but this speaks to you like you need to you needed to hear this by the way
um
But yeah, like I
I'm just like I'm like angry
Like I'm just like I feel like you've been feeling with this a lot
Like this feeling a lot and you're like team is like kind of sick of it
They're just like dude
Is not that deep
And they're kind of just like over
I don't know why that's the feeling I get I'm just like it's like frustration
Um, maybe it also could be a little bit of frustration in your part. Sorry to bring you down to your brain and
They just want what's best for you and they know that's not what they don't they know
That's not what's good for you. You know that didn't make any sense
Because you know what I was trying to say they know that's not good for you
um
Night of cups creativity romance charming imagination
Idealist beauty graceful artistic
I think that's an autistic tactful diplomatic mediator negotiator. These are those traits you do have and you're not using any of them
stop
ah
Stop being jealous
This is me shaking you
That candle's still holding on
Oh, see everybody loves you. You don't have to be jealous of anything just work on just focus on yourself
Move in silence get your own bags sis. You know does that make any sense? Does that like resonate at all? I'm so sorry. I was like
Yeah
You're enough
You're enough exactly you're enough
Uh that was for you bro if she breathes just focus on yourself
Hell yeah
I
Canough precisely
Think parts resonated cool. That's all that matters if something sometimes like
I'll tell you something and it might not be like entirely
What you were expecting to hear wanting to hear but you'll hear something that you need to hear at least
You know like there'd be one part that just like
Sometimes you need to hear something coming from somebody else like you've been telling yourself it before
Sometimes you just need to hear it from like a bunny anime girl on the internet, you know
Why was that four out of ten?
Um
Doki I legit but we are
Oh, maybe it's art related
Maybe it's like I'm not a good enough artist
I mean, that's why stop comparing yourself to other people
That was a weak burp you're a weak bitch now what sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I didn't mean
Uh
I'm a scorpio. I got divorced at the end of last year. What's in store for my love life in the next year. Okay, and non amuse
Love reading love reading. Let's get a love reading. Do you think you're yours?
Do you think you need to give yourself some like some time?
I don't know how long you were with this person. This is just general advice by the way, but like
Big feeling that you need like to heal a little bit
and not worry about
Actively getting like finding someone else in love
I feel like this is a time for you kind of to learn a lot about yourself
With this free time because sometimes you're with someone
For a long time
and you forget
About your individuality
Or how you were before you were with them the best type of partner is where you can be yourself and to kind of just grow
But if you feel like you're living as somebody else to be with your
Partner, then that's not the thing and I feel like next year for you
I don't even have to pull cards for this will be kind of a year of like self-discovery
That's great advice. Let's do it. Um, but yeah, let's
You didn't mean it. It was dessert. Let's let's let's get some cards
Full unknown he moves. I knew they said that they talked at one point, but I can't recall
What the name was that spoke
Regarding the the horse. I know it was a dr. P. It was somebody else
Something original. Yes, you're married for six years, but we had a pretty healthy relationship. We weren't trying to live for through each other. Okay
Why'd you get divorced? I'm sorry
Do you guys have like different like
Directions you wanted to go in like I don't know how you expect the date or like love life stuff
If you guys are living together, I'm just a little lost
Are you guys like Polly you're gonna be okay if you start like
So she starts seeing other people. I have a lot of questions. I'm kind of interested in the tea
I was married for ten years you team were done different life priorities
Also, he realized he was trans and I'm straight. I got a bit complicated. Also were Polly. Okay. All right. It's funny because like I had a friend
um
Who got married?
they were a lesbian couple and
One of them discovered he was trans
and it did like you're totally entitled if you're like not attracted to that like that
gender like
to
Really it's it's I bet it's hard
because
Honestly, I can't really speak on it because I've never had the experience but seeing what like my friends because they're both my friends
what they went through because they were trying to make it work, but it was just like
Yeah, it was definitely the like different life priorities
Hi Nori
Yeah, yeah, I wasn't like oh yeah, like it's not like you give it a good try like you know
Go don't you for that. It's hard because like
if you're
Like a man and you're not attracted to men, but your partner decides they want to be him
It's hard because you know you try to push through you try to love them
But like your your body, you know loves what they love. So it's like I can't can't you know
I can't can't really blame you for that. Thank you for being honest about that by the way
I I really appreciate you being vulnerable in the chat right now and kind of telling telling what's going on
Hi Nori
And
Again, I apologize something original because I what I've been telling you a lot hasn't been like resonating with you a lot
So I hope this reading the cards will resonate with you if they don't I apologize
Um, but yeah, so I hope I hope you do get something out of this
Maybe just even talking about it is like good. I know you guys had an amicable
Break-up and stuff, but you know still sometimes it's just good to like talk like it still hurts
You know when you have to when you end a relationship poly or otherwise. I bet
I hope I love you what nori nori you're not even
That doesn't make any sense
Oh
I don't know why the song
Popped into my head um
From what is it called trolling the chocolate factory
Trauma bowl the chat I brought the bowl
Um
The trolling the chocolate factory song
If you want to view paradise simply look around and view it so I feel like
I feel like
It'll be a lot of just like taking in the the flowers and like kind of just like
Seeing the good the next year just like staying positive
you know
I actually said you go mirror about it earlier
Because what you said really impacted me, but I didn't want to feel feels dump in the chat. Oh, that's okay
This is this is a fine time to do it
like that's
Because I'm asking you so don't feel bad
Hi rena you need to get off my desk
There's too much on my desk right now. Really pilot. Do you want to say hi?
Here you can say hi to chat
It's rena
You don't see rena that often
You
So you have the hierophant
Oh my god, I can't hear my freaking nose now in reverse you have seven of pentacles
And upright and upright and then you have um the sun
In reverse and it's funny because it says literally the first thing is this feeling down temporary
So, of course, you're naturally going to go through this period where you just feel sad you feel down, but I'll get to that
So the hierophant
Is usually represented by like a priest usually represents like traditional and it's funny
because um
You don't have a traditional sort of relationship, you know
Bye rena
Do you all care if you share something that's been going on if you'll want me to that's just thing go saying something's going on there recently. Um
You can that's fine. Uh, I won't be able to acknowledge it until after the reading that I hope you don't mind
Oh, yeah
But just so you guys know. Yes, um, like when I'm doing your personal reading for someone, it's fine
But normally I don't usually allow, you know trauma dumping in chat, but you know, it's fine
Sometimes it's good to get it out. Sometimes chat can be your therapist. But anyways, let me continue. That is burning bright
so
I feel like sticking to your personal beliefs and kind of staying true to yourself is very beneficial for you right now
um non commitment again, I feel it's really relevant to the um
poly stuff
Uh challenging belief and authority originality rebellion and conventionality and new methods
I feel like you're going I I do feel like you're going to get into a relationship
interestingly enough like pretty soon
um
I feel like this person is going to kind of match your energy and be like kind of this rebellious
sort of
person
And they're going to be kind of okay with your lifestyle and what you've been through
um, and they're going to respect
Kind of like your own
Aspirations and belief system and all that stuff and it's kind they're just going to mesh with you pretty well
um
I just yeah, I feel like that's
Like this is
It's pretty straightforward
um
It's going to happen in a roundabout way that you don't expect
Like you're it's like, you know, you find love in the most unconventional places. Um, seven appendicles long-term investments again
All right, like I'm saying I feel like you'll be getting into a relationship pretty soon. It will be a long-term investment, you know
Uh sustained patience. It's going to take time. It's going to be you know
a learning curve
While you live with this person and kind of just like being
With other people then being with other people
um
uh
Because I like I've had because like I've had friends
um
Well, I had friends. They're still friends. Uh, I have a friend who is Polly and she has told me
Kind of like the mental
Life's like it's like I because I I personally don't
understand it or subscribe to that
But I was curious so I asked her to explain it to me because I like to know the why and the how behind things
And I know that trust and communication is a very big part of relationships in general
But especially when you're in like what like a what's it called like a polyamory?
poly
Q
poly couple, I don't know. Um
But it's going it's going to take
It's like yes, like of course you can like date other people while you're dating while you were with that person
but still gonna hurt
You know because
And introducing somebody else to the relationship is requires a lot of trust
And now that you guys are completely separate
Um, it's going to take a lot of like patience to introduce this person into your life
Well, also not being complete but while being completely separated from this person. It's going to be kind of a new experience. Um,
but yeah
I hope that makes sense. It's hard to talk because again, I'm not super familiar on the subject
um
But yeah, but then like after the hard work and the perseverance of working on this relationship
You'll you know, you'll start stuff with them. Maybe you'll be able to you know move out or it's still say amicable with your ex
um
That's tough though. That's tough six years. That's pretty tough. Um
And then, you know, it'll it'll be it'll be a growth period
Harvest results profits and planning. Yeah, and then you know
I feel good about it. I feel really good about it. You'll have this temp of the sun in reverse
You'll have this temporary feeling down
um
And
Hold on my cats are doing something. There'll be an interruption probably. I see you playing it. Hello. What are you doing?
Hey
Okay
All right, there might be
There might be um
It's not like you're good together rich you get to see yeah, yeah
like I still can't quite wear my head around it but like I I
I get what people mean. I just like again
mentally I just
I don't know. I just yeah
But that's besides the point. Um
Blocked happiness so uh, I feel like something will come up or someone kind of
tries to prevent you from getting what you want
um
Like someone's gonna come out and try to like trash everything
and be like super pessimistic and conceded about it like
Oh, just be like really kind of nasty
And I don't know who this is. I feel like this will be the person like I feel like your
X partner will also meet someone and they'll just be a dick. I'm sorry. I don't know why
um
But you know
Stay in your own lane and you'll be continued to be fine. Rhino. What are you doing?
Thank you. You're knocking stuff over. I appreciate that. Nope. Don't grab my chest
She always tries to grab me and then ends his subscription. Now you get put on camera for your crimes
Here comes the cat
Don't worry. She's not near the candle although she looks like she is on the camera. The light is brighter than it is. Okay
Um
He already met like three people two of whom are really bad. Yeah, so like I feel like they just
Not cool peeps, you know
sorry
I forgot their pronouns. I apologize. Um
I imagine the polycule was almost as good as the challenge is needed for community to trust
Full people. Yeah, I could not handle more than one person
Are we a polycule guys?
Wait
Wait a second
Huh, wait a sec
Rhino part two
We hear them. Are we this is more reverse hair? Yeah
Yeah
Look the thousands in polish
I don't know
Is it a slip pop
All right, but I hope that makes sense. Yeah, I feel like you'll get like I just feel really good about like you'll get what you need
Pretty soon
Yeah, stay hopeful
Where does cards go?
Listen to woman by doja cat
Okay
Hair and Malif Shibi has one collective that's true
For me a big part is it is it is not feeling possessive
Like I don't own my partner they can do what they want what's important
So they consider my feelings that I am there. I see
the possibly tarot cards for animals
I have met people who claim to do that. I
don't quite
believe it, but sure
um
Emily
If you're still here
You would like an overview of september. Oh personally. Emily. Emily. Are you alive? Emily? Emily?
Emily are you here?
Speak to me
No problem. Oh, hi
Hello
Emily popped up real quick she's like what you rang I've been here the whole time
I'd like to add if it helps. I'm australian so I'm going to spring and it's gonna be busy. Oh, okay
I forgot you guys have an upside down land. You have different
Seasons it's so odd to me
I remember cuz like I live in america. So I'm just like what it's spring in september
But uh good good good. I don't know why I don't know why good for you just pop into good for you. Emily
Good for you. I don't know what you did recently, but good for you
You
Upside down cards are right set the reverse is actually the upright imagine. That'd be funny
All right
Everything's upside down. All right. What is emily?
half in store
For the month of september actually hold on
I
Distractions
It's my cat or distract me again. Hello
What are you doing
I don't know what's happening
What
Then they go quiet. That's so weird
Why are you guys making those eyes?
I thought it was hello no ghost
It's funny everything's coming out upside down
I can't
Why is everything coming out in reverse?
Some visitors are peeking the camera. What do you mean? Looking respectfully
I don't
Okay, I was about to be this is also in reverse. I'm gonna have some issues
Well reverse doesn't mean bad it just means like
Honestly, it could mean any kind of mean again. No cards are bad
All right, we got two swords in reverse king of cups in reverse and we got two cups
upright
Are you
Why does this feel relationship related?
I feel like I'm completely wrong about this, but I'm just gonna say what I'm gonna say
Um
Chat am I missing the what why are you guys looking?
What I don't understand
Oh wait, I looked over at my camera
All right, now I know what you guys shut up shut up chat I see it now
Have you seen that tick-tock of a girl?
It's like when a guy is cute and he makes you laugh and she starts like laughing and then her ass looks like she just goes
It's like really
Like really exaggerated like shaking your ass. It's funny
I'm trying the perfect times
All right, Emily back to you. I don't know why I feel like
There is some masculine energy that's just kind of like not doing it for you
Um, they're not kind of emotionally vested there. Are you in a situation ship? No, I don't know
Um, I don't know but like just like negative masculine energy
anyways
Two of swords
Time to make a move reached an impasse stalemate deadlock decision conclusion to be had
Is someone like
I'm the world's most single Pringle. I'm so proud of you for that go-off sis. Um
I still get like some sort of masculine energy like
Like you're being provided with a choice
uh, because again
sort like I would say too is like
Choice I might get some clarification to this because like you gotta make a move you gotta move don't be in a stalemate
You gotta do something king of cups
Emotionally manipulative and abusive cold mootiness withdrawn selfish and anxious
Is this your dad like who who is the masculine figure in your life that is acting this way?
What's going on is this for somebody else?
You got some clarification cards
Oh
Hold on I just dropped a lot of cards
Is this a shitty co-worker me that's probably it because I'm like is there like some like shitty dude that like is in your life right now?
Yes, I did turn the thing
I did turn the comet thing to make it a chat box. What of it?
I mean to make it a webcam box because I was too lazy to make my own what of it
You work with all women
Well one of them's like no
What is I can't use my mouse
The cards are vague. You're correct. They are very vague
Why can't I turn my webcam back on there we go
Maybe whoever gets you rejected is a dude and he's in the way. Who knows camera down
And like I turned it off so I could bend over to take stuff up because I didn't want to be sheen
Again this could be stuff that happened by the way
Like it doesn't have to be immediately happening because it's for the month of September. So just like
Be on the lookout for a really shitty dude. I don't know why just like
There is a really shitty dude around
Um, I'm gonna get some clarification quads
It's funny because these are cards that fell the lovers in reverse
The emperor
Queen of wands in reverse
Those are the cards that fell. I don't know if they mean anything
But I just feel like be on your guard. Someone shitty is happening. Um
Let me get some clarification because I could be it seems like I like these don't resonate so I might be totally reading them wrong
Because it seems like this looks like a love reading at first glance, but it's it's clearly not
I'm missing key information
It's good thing you work with all women that must be fun
I
Is it a shitty job
Because it's literally is coming off like a love reading for some reason
You got the devil in reverse knight of swords and you got three of wands
The cards are not carding what's going on
My candle is twitching a lot in reply
Tension in the workplace
I can't put my finger on it
Because it says leaving an abusive toxic situation
And I'm like toxic relationship. I just feel like you should be on your guard from like either a toxic friendship like a dude
Like I'm getting a lot of negative masculine energy from this
Because you have knight of swords ambitious fast thinking
perfectionists
dare like I feel like there's a
Dude this doesn't think before he leaps and he's kind of a prick
It seems like Emily is unreadable. She could be
Recovery
Leaving a piece of attachment freedom facing shadows independence reclaiming power could be leaving the job
Toss the crappy yeah, I just feel like you should just like there'll be a really like negative male energy that comes along
And I just really want you to be on their guard because they
Suck again
This isn't stuff that is happening now to stuff to be out where for a month of september
So for you in particular Emily, I feel like if you have any male friends or if you have any
Like people like again male like this could be just like masculine energy
You know, I couldn't it doesn't have to be a dude. Um, just be on the like I feel like someone's just gonna be a major
Toxic person and show their true colors the way I'm looking at this
You'll have however, you'll have one person in your corner that sticks up for you with those two of cups
They got your back
But you gotta be careful because somebody else is lurking around
Going after you they're trying to shit on you the month of september
um
Guys you don't have to
Guys you don't have to try to rationalize the cards to fit her if it doesn't fit if it doesn't resonate
That doesn't resonate if it doesn't make any sense to her then it then it's not for her, you know, and then it doesn't
Yeah, that's good
It's a masculine energy aggressive. No not per se
not really
Me trying to tarot
Yeah, you don't have to try to like contort the cards into like someone's situation because then it's then it's not really a reading
You know, but for me what I think
Tdlr just getting tl dr
There will be someone
with masculine energy
And here i'll tell you what masculine energy means. Let me just look up some sort of freaking definition
divine masculine energy
Uh, so divine masculine is a spiritual concept that represents sense of qualities
um traditionally associated with masculinity which is strength action rationality integrity and emotional integrity
So there should be someone who has these really positive qualities, but they're gonna turn out to be a piece of shit. Um, so be careful
You'll have somebody in your corner that will back you up and support you. Um
There might be delays and stuff that you've been working on because of this person they'll kind of try to like undermine you
Lack of planning and progress setback obstacles frustration unexpected delays
Yeah, unexpectedly this person's just like like wait
They were a dick
What like that's kind of it. Um, and then
Yeah, then the devil. Yeah, they're really like I just
Be careful just be careful
I hope that doesn't resonate
Because that just sounds like it just sucks like this person's just shitty
I hope that that doesn't happen to you the month of september
Oh, yeah, I honestly hope it doesn't resonate at all. I hope i'm full of shit right now
I hope i'm i'm out of spirit juice because I am super tired actually
It's only 10 18 and i've already taken a nap and i'm stupid tired. Uh, let me see who
Um toxic guy once he shows up. Hey Emily psych blocks a voice
Yeah spirit juice. Yeah, i'm out of spirit juice, man
Maybe the yeah, if a yeah, maybe the plan is she stays a single pringle true. That's a good point
Could be someone comes up. They're like, hey, you want to go on a date and you're like you seem like sleazy as hell
No, thank
Okay
Emily i'm so sorry if that didn't resonate again
It doesn't have to just take with the grain of salt
There's a remaining guard. Yeah, I feel like just be on your guard
Someone's not too nice right now. Just be just that's all I gotta say
um
I'm
Guys trying to take Emily
Um
I'ma chalk up no one's special question to did I make the right choice?
You guys have sad names, why is your name no one special?
Alien invasion
What's what's happening? There's an alien invasion
Turn that no legs for you
Oh, it's a raid. Oh ali's raiding
There's no youtube's broken and they don't have the chat message anymore
Hello. Hi. Hi
Hi raiders. Welcome. Welcome. Hi raiders. My name is she be cottonbomb
I am your favorite girl failure dom of gen one
Uh
Availers gen one indulge. I can't talk and I'm doing tarot because it's summer we
Already made a spell jar
But I hope you stick around I am goofy. I like to do really fun voices and go and do voice acting
I was gonna say something stupid
But I'm not gonna say I'm gonna have a good impression. Oh wait. I want to make fun of uh ali for a second. Um
So normally
Normally I don't wear this outfit all the time
Because we me and ali have a um
Have a have a collab coming up and so we've been in a group chat with with some other peeps
And she
Literally after we've been in a group chat for three days realizes that I have a ball gag
on my model
and then
I uh
In ruy are like wait. I just noticed that too
And then they're like I'm like, well, yeah, I'm a rope bunny
I have
I like I'm a rope bunny and I have shabari ropes and I'm a bunny. They're like you're a bunny
And I'm like, are you fucking with me guys? And they're like, what you got shabari ropes? I'm like guys
Have you guys just been staring at my boobs the entire time and they're like no and I'm like
Yeah
I feel bad because they probably can't talk because I have subscriber mode on I'm so sorry
Oh, but welcome raiders
Please stick around. Please hang out. Have a good time
Um, all right, so let me too. Let me do no one special is reading
Brash is slumber
Me this this candle is still burning guys
It's still going the the it's it's um
Look the color is blue green the flame
Very interesting that usually means I was a spirit nearby
At least they recognized you as a person and not a domino. That's a good point actually I didn't think about that
Cards are the wrong way. I did think about that
Afterwards, I'm like, oh
They actually like saw me for me
Jesus frick. They saw me for me. Oh geez
Well
I can already tell you're a really disorganized
Uh, no one special because I cannot seem to get these cards in my hands properly
You feel like you have no hold on stuff
So that's what's currently going on with me
We don't stare we're we ogle
Okay, let's start eating the glass perhaps it just starts melting the glass down that'd be really cool
I stole those from somebody's wedding by the way
I went to a wedding and those were the things and I'm just like thank you. I will take
They a lot of candle holders and I was like yoink
I'm kidding. They're like the they were like the centerpieces guys. That was a bad shuffle. They were the centerpieces I didn't steal
I'm not a club too. I swear
I swear
Hell yeah
You know shout out to Emily for like being probably the only female that watches me
I'm trying to attract more girls, but it's hard because you know, I'm a whore
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding
Who says it's only her
I looked at my oh, yeah, I'm morgan. That's in morgan. Also morgan
Ah, what was it? Uh, I was looking at my analytics. So it's morgan and emily are the only girls that watch me
Usually vaude game. Oh nice. Um
The two women I was looking it was like
1.8
Percent
is female
Or 1.7. Actually, let me check right now. I'll tell you right now
In ventriloquist form how many females watch me percentage wise
analytics
Oh, it went out
It went out
It's smoking I finally went out
When your viewers are on youtube 12 p.m. To 6 p.m
Shout out to the
0.1 percent of the the 65 year old that watches me
I have no people from the ages of 55 to 64 watch me 45 to 54. However 2.2
35 to 44 9.7
25 to 34
18 to 24
41 13 to 17 is 0.8. You can't watch me go away
Female 1.9
Let's go
1.9 ladies gentlemen, I'm close to 2%
I have a lot of canadian and uk people won't watch me
1.9
All right
I
Sense a lot of anxiety
A lot of tears stress
I do the right thing and I make the right choice. I was just gonna fuck me up forever
Let's go
Raina
Why are you yelling in my bedroom?
Creating a female account right now
It's probably the people who walk get like sent my shorts to be honest with you because like a lot of shorts
Pulling like a younger crowd
Do you think I can order a hello kitty happy meal?
The high priestess in reverse
What time is it 10 27
Although I had McDonald's the other day, I don't want to keep eating junk
I think I'm gonna get the hello fresh stuff because I just like having that structure and then I can supplement it with like
Other groceries and stuff. It's actually cheaper because I spend like 250 on groceries. That's like a hundred dollars
Wow, they don't have a lot to say they don't want to talk come on
I want a special spiritual team. Where are you? Thank you very much
Kind of one more card, please
Is that it? Is that the card if you give me another card when I shuffle through the deck? I'll swap it
I thought about it
Are you sure are you sure about that? Oh
Okay
They're like I have something to say
One person one of them was like wait
Wait a moment. Oh my god hair reveal
I
Hello, welcome
Where omg it's hairy
I've had hello fresh before and like blue apron all that stuff. I actually like did a lot. It was pretty cool
I like cooking cooking is fun
Welcome mothman card this card
I don't know. I just got like heaviness from this card
Raina
Who are you talking to?
I'm here
Why are you yelling in the bedroom? Usually you yell in the back and Raina likes to yell in the bathtub because of the up who sticks
Raina's my cat
By the way
If you're new here, I have three cats
Okay
High priestess in reverse
seven of cups
in reverse
queen of wands
judgment
upright
No one special
Do you want me to be blunt or do you want me to sugarcoat things?
You
Bobblehead
Can you keep up?
I always like to ask
Baby boy can you use my
Go for it. All right, then
All right
Somebody stop. Sorry. I don't know like why randomly stand with stuff
So high priestess in reverse
Locked intuition clouded insight doubt secrets cognitive dissonance disconnect superficiality confusion hidden motives
Uh
This is like you right now. You're full of a lot of doubt whether you made the right choice and did the right
It made the right decision with this whole move you just did. Um, what was it again? Hold on
Yeah
Yeah financial decision. Um, so it's a lot of self-doubt
Did you something did you go with your gut? Oh hi rena. Are you coming to?
Oh
ma'am
Hi rena
Could I help you? Where are you going? Why are you climbing me?
You're actually warm and she's purring
Sorry, she had she's had to butting the mic
It's
Yeah, it's okay. Don't worry. Don't worry for showing late. You're here now. That's all that matters
So I care about that you show up
About her leg whenever
She's I can't really move. I wish I could show you
But I would my face is in the way. Um
She you see her tail
I can't really see it. She's really standing on my hip
In her
Going at my chair purring and rubbing on it ma'am. Are you okay? Oh, she's going for the mic
She's going for the mic guys. Where are you going?
Hello
I need to clip your claws. Your back claws are sharp
Yeah, so it was a gut decision. Okay, that's what I thought. Um
I feel like I should have been more logical
Um
I feel like if somebody helped you come to that decision, they had their own hidden motive
Um, and they didn't really have your best interests at heart
Um, and yeah, they clouded your insight and kind of like
Didn't really help you out there. Uh
Seven of cups
So you see the cups there's a lot of choices, but some are bad
You have like
Kind of a dragon. You have the tower crystals gems reads snakes jewelry masks
Uh masks is like a false face
Uh alignment
Not being distracted by other things clarity illusion ends restored
I think again hindsight is 2020
You're gonna realize it probably wasn't the best decision. Um
In the kind of the idea the illusion
That it was correct is going to end will achieve that clarity
Will you realize the mistake?
Um
But that's okay. This is alignment. It wasn't for you
Yes, it might have not been the best thing
But it is in line alignment in a teaching moment for you
Queen Reino
Hi
Where are you going?
Reino's gonna read your cards. Oh look
I'm gonna grab it stop staring at the flame. Can you read that?
Why are you just staring at the candle?
Ooh, she poppin. That's why Reino's staring at the candle
She's looking at the camera all intense goddamn
Good fortune but falls you traveler. Now she's just here for screeches
Hey
You
Why are you staring at the candle? Usually Reino doesn't care about candles. She's very intently staring at it
No, you can't pull on my shoulder. No, you can't
Okay, all right. I have a cat on my shoulder. This is how I hold her
Um
Queen of wands
In
reverse
Yeah, she'd be looking fire. It's going really well
Demanding lack of self-worth
Queen of wonders demanding lack of self-worth drama deceit and finality vengeful anger jealous opposition low confidence selfish and temperamental
And
You have like this Cleopatra looking lady
Kind of sitting staring off to the distance she's a black cat on her lap
Sort of it's kind of almost like in opposition to the high priestess
Because you see like you have the moon and there's also the the moon on this one
It was definitely yeah an emotional gut decision, but it wasn't for your greatest good
Please don't let this make you spiral into a lack of self-worth
I feel like you really shit on yourself when you make a mistake
um
Yes, it might have not been the best decision
But it was a learning moment
Do not become angry don't let it consume you
Because it's not it's not worth it, you know, and it's it's not worth it
You
Like how wiki everything looks this car looks fucking rad though. I love like seraphim. You can see the eye
Oh, look at you got an eye right there. You got an eye right here
However
This
Was meant to happen again hindsight 2020 a learning opportunity you're gonna grow you're gonna understand stuff from those
Judgment final you're gonna you know, you're gonna gain better judgment
final decisions
absolutions wake up call
Intercalling life purpose self-evaluation awakening and reckoning
You're gonna look at yourself in the mirror and you're gonna be like, okay
Maybe this wasn't the best decision. Maybe I shouldn't have done this
Maybe this blah blah blah and this is going to expire a sort of self-discovery how you can do stuff to make up for it
you know
Sometimes you gotta hit rock bottom to get you know go to the top as they say
Um, it's gonna be a wake-up call. You're gonna be like
Yay, I should have done something differently
And that's okay. It was necessary. I'm gonna give you one more card because I feel like you need a positive in here
Typically, I I love them with the accurate angels. It's hard to shuffle with rena. I'm so sorry. Um, you're gonna
You might
Reena, it's okay. You might get a little bit of bitty
I'm so sorry
Because I have to lean forward
Oh
No tummy for free
Reena is so hard to shuffle with you on my shoulder
What
No, she's looking behind
So you have some positive okay rena you can't get all comfortable on my shoulder like you're gonna lay down
I don't have the strength
No tummy one no tummy allowed
She give it and she take it the way I think she farted because it smells now
Thanks a lot right now
If you was farting up a storm the other day, oh my god, I was dying next to her
I'm like dang girl you need a sheet
Okay
Can I get
Thank you. All right
There's one of two ways this can go brother
The hermit or the star all right
all right
be not afraid
The hermit in reverse you have a star upright harbor if you continue to linger on the mistake
and not
You know
Decide to work on better judgment and move forward
You will
self isolate
Don't experience loneliness because you're gonna be so worked up. You're going to self isolate withdrawal being stuck repeating past mistakes
You're going to be on the cycle where you keep doing the same things over and over again this karmic cycle
We're wrapped up in no don't do that
Loneliness antisocial rejection
Then you're gonna be scared to do anything else because you're afraid you're gonna fail again
We don't want that except the loss
and move on
If I can pick hello the star
Not the frenzied fling
This candle's getting short. I have another one though. I have another green man cable
Um hope renewal
Miracles rejuvenation faith
purpose
inspiration positively healing inner clarity
Again, like I said, you will grow from this
If you can if you just accept it
You'll have hope
You'll find a new purpose this thing might have not worked out that you put all your stuff into
But you'll have that clarity
You'll gain that judgment and you'll move forward and you'll be it'll be positive
The star is such a good positive card. It's such a beautiful card too
This woman looking up at the sky
Really it's a spirituality really in tune
With like you to uh start here to start there. I feel like she's really in tune with like the universe or like a god if you believe in god
um, but she's also outpouring her emotions, so maybe
Outpouring your emotions
I don't know if you believe in god or the universe or kind of just like I don't know just pray or something pray on it
What the people say pray on it
Or talk to someone about it
We don't believe in that. Um
Pro-pro-pro-principal point
Jennifer Kerlage
She struggled accepting herself into real practice or acting skills. It was my 30s things. So yeah, exactly
Like you don't have to put all your eggs in one basket as a matter of how old you are depending no matter what whatever you can still
Move forward and grow
you know
So like don't get caught up
And again take with a grain of salt. I could be completely fucking wrong. You could be a okay. Don't even worry about it, bro
I don't want you to stress. Don't even stress. Nobody's stress
All right
All right, you got it
Let's get a general card to close the night off
I'm kind of stressed
uh
But yeah, let me let me know how you feel about that reading. I apologize if it was a lot
I don't want you to have more anxiety again
You don't have to believe in the shit that i'm telling you
Oh, baby girl, my favorite card the magician
She stresses us when she drinks milkshakes. I had a milkshake to contain
Don't tell anybody I had a milkshake
um
Do I need one another card clarification
Nope, okay, that's it
No, I didn't take lactate. That's why I pooped so much today
The magician, however, it's in reverse. So this is something close out the night that we all have to be mindful about
manipulation unfulfilled potential scattered energy
Wasting resources illusions out of touch out of touch. I thought it was out of reach out of touch and deception
I feel like this pertains to me personally
um
Because my I feel like my energy has been very scattered. I'm going this way that I'm going that way
Um, I feel like I'm wasting my energy. I'm wasting resources because I'm not just like kind of like focusing in
I'm kind of like going all over the place and it's it's stressing me out. It's making me procrastinate. You know that like
I don't know what it means when you
Have stuff to do and you want to get it done
But you keep doing other stuff and procrastinating and put it off because you just don't want to do that one thing
Although it's not so hard because when you do it, you'll be fine
Like that's me
So that's what like that's for me. That's probably like that's me right there. Um, but for some of you guys, I don't know
You might be dealing with like someone lying to you manipulating you be careful about that. Um
Out of touch maybe like kind of be more in tune with other people it might be a little out of touch you might have
Pissed somebody off because you didn't understand something
It's nice getting to see you do some divination. I hope you do more in the future. Oh, thank you
Yeah, it will probably be a rare thing to be honest like, um
I like really get excited when Halloween's around the corner. So that's why I wanted to do like a summer mean
But um, I probably won't do this again until Halloween
Um
Just because it really isn't my
Me like it's Emmy's thing. So I don't want to like
um
Enroach upon her k-fabe more than I already am
Because like this has nothing to do with the Dominique drinks dummy mommy
You know
And I like to keep my content kind of in line with that. So
Yeah, I definitely want to do a stream with her because I would like to see how she reads
Um, I would like to read for her and I would like her to read me. I don't get read that often
Um, like Toma looks probably like one of the only people that reads for me. So
Yeah, it would be it would be a lot of fun. I would like it a lot
But
Feels tiring feels like I'm possessed
Hey, uh, I'm not great. I'm very tired. I'm like so like my body hurts
Oh, I'm in so much pain now
I took a lot
I love the magician
Oh
Yeah, but try to like focus up. I think end of the end of the day just focus up everybody
Um, don't waste your potential. Don't waste your energy. Just focus on one thing a task
Take a one step at a time. I think we all need to hear that sometimes. Just take a one step at a time
I'm out of that. Oh, I have some polo sample
Oh, little sample
Or did I don't know where
I don't know what happened to my
Lighter it just walked through legs and walked away. I don't know if I had it in my hand and I took it with me somewhere
Who knows?
Let's go get some rest. No, I am I'm gonna go get some rest. Let's see if I can like this
This looks it looks like I'm soldering something
I
Cleanse the area. Thank you spirits for coming and joining with us today and lending your insight
You may go off to whatever you came from now and have a good rest of your night
You never want to blow out a candle by the way that represents your spiritual team. It's kind of disrespectful
She just want to snuff it
Or sometimes and I didn't have like a candle snuffer. I would just look like my fingers give him a part of me
Just beep
That kind of like the burn
Whoo
Yeah, I hope you guys liked it. Um
Yeah, I'll probably do this again and listen to um around Halloween
And uh
Yeah, I don't really know what else to say
I'm really tired and I don't know what to say now
Kind of like brain dead
I thought how boomi stayed away during this type of stream. It's because I threatened him with a water bottle twice
Because when I was setting up he kept hopping up here. I was like, no
No, not gonna happen, bro. Here's your toy. Go away
Um
Boomi likes actually to be around when I do card readings
He's my little my little cat familiar
He took Soleil's place
Soleil used to be my kitty cat familiar
Before she passed away. All right
That's fine. Is there a streaming? Yes, it's her time
Uh, let me
Let me clear my throat
Let's pull the blicky
Yeah, we're gonna go rate a zero. I'll go wish her happy birthday
Um, I wanted to like this is why I wanted to end stream at nine because so I can just rate it in turn then
But you know here I am and it's 11
Wait, but yeah, you know, just be like that sometimes
It just be like that sometimes
Where is she there it is
Is she still streaming is she gonna be still streaming? She probably will she streams for a long time
She's like me and Strani which streams for like five hours for no reason
Um, but yeah, go shower her with love. Thank you so much for the donos. I'm going to be read for you
Oh my gosh, look who it is
Boomi just showed up
Boomi
I think my belly it's poking out because his these leggings are too small
Here comes the and I'm also sitting like a
Oh, man, here comes the boomi
Here he comes
Is my cat boomi his name is metro boomin
Ishnip
Where you going?
I
Sir
Checking my work, please don't flash the camera
Haha, nobody can see me kiss you
You
Why are you so close to the camera?
What are you doing?
What are you doing boomi? He's just staring
How do you
What are you doing?
Oh your pet look at him look at him open his mouth. Hold on. Let's see if he does it
He'll open his mouth when I pet him. That's really funny
Oh, I love him so much even though he's stinky
Are you gonna lay right there?
Damn boor
You take up the whole freaking desk
Well, um
What are you doing? He's just sniffing the stand
No, don't flash the camera
All right, bye
Are you leaving?
He almost fell over he'll let you know like cats like lean into you. Oh, he's coming back for round two
He's going for my phone
Sir
What are you
Brother
I could smell your butthole from here, please please put that away
It smells like fish
Where are you going?
No Molly's back
Okay
You just hanging out
Why are you you gonna bite the camera?
Oh
What do you
No
He just reached for the camera. Okay, my boomy
He's assuming control the brock. I'd be funny if I just ended the stream when he when he reached for the for the camera
That would have been funny
Too bad. I'm slow on the draw. All right. Bye everybody. Get lots of love to Azura. Bye
I should have ended stream a long time ago to read into her. Bye
He
Stinker stanky haram just like stinky boomy
Bye, thank you for letting me show you one of my special interests